Chat hier. Da bin ich. Ich muss aber noch, ich muss mich noch umziehen.
Warte mal kurz, Chat aufmachen auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
So.
Ich muss noch Socken anziehen hier.
Ich bin gerade eben fertig rennen gewesen.
Vor zehn Minuten oder so bin ich das Hofdor rein.
Ja, noch nicht mal, noch nicht mal zehn Minuten bin ich das Hofdor rein.
Ich habe gerade
meine Hose und mein T-Shirt gerade in die Ecke geschmissen, so dass es hoffentlich trocknet.
Und jetzt muss ich mich erst einmal kurz umziehen.
Heute ging es ab, Leute. Also das hatte ich auch noch nicht. Ohne Mist. Ich bin heute gerannt.
Und nach fünf Kilometer.
Also ich bin schon die etwas größere Runde gerannt. Also meine normale Runde ist 6,2 Kilometer. Die etwas größere ist
7,8 bis 8, so je nachdem, wie viele Kurven ich laufe. Und so nach fünf Kilometer habe ich mir heute gedacht, okay.
Eigentlich
kommt es dir so vor, als hast du noch nicht mal angefangen.
Da bin ich einfach noch eine größere Runde.
Bin heute 10,3 Kilometer gerannt. Das erste Mal, dass ich über zehn Kilometer gerannt bin. Und gar nicht so langsam. Ich muss das gleich mal auf
Twitter posten. Gar nicht so langsam, ey.
So, ich muss mal kurz Headset absetzen.
Ja, richtig Stonks. Ich weiß, also das hatte ich auch noch nicht. Ich habe heute gar nicht gedacht.
Also ich hatte heute echt das Gefühl, dass nicht ich renne.
Sondern irgendein Kerl, der trainiert ist.
Kam mir nicht so vor, wie ich beim Rennen heute.
Also das scheint doch, es scheint doch ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Wenn man das konstant macht.
Also ich hätte ja nie im Leben gedacht. Ich muss das gleich mal auf Twitter posten.
Ich hätte ja nie im Leben gedacht,
dass
ich mal, also ich habe angefangen vor drei Monaten oder so, dass ich mal
in etwas über einer Stunde
10,3 Kilometer renne.
Und das Erstaunliche ist,
ich bin gar nicht mal so groß im Arsch.
Ich muss das gerade mal kurz posten.
Ich poste das immer auf Twitter.
Nicht so sehr, um irgendwie zu zeigen, dass ich der krasseste Dude bin, weil das bin ich, was das mit den Geschwindigkeiten hat.
Sondern einfach nur, weil ich selbst verfolgen will,
wie gut das läuft, ja.
Ich gucke mir regelmäßig selbst auf Twitter an.
Mein Arsch läuft.
Ich gucke mir regelmäßig auf Twitter an, so die ersten Sachen, die ich gepostet habe.
Versus zu den aktuellen Sachen, da stelle ich immer fest, okay,
ich bin doch etwas schneller geworden.
Twitter Post ist raus.
Nee, glaube ich nicht. Wie viel schaffst du?
Bei 10 Kilometer, also ich habe, ich kann es euch zeigen hier, Nitter, Max FPS.
Ja, das bin ich gerade gerannt.
Und ich hatte echt, ohne Scheiß, ich hatte zum ersten Mal den Eindruck, das bin gar nicht ich, der da rennt,
sondern das geht viel zu easy für mich.
Das ist eigentlich echt in Ordnung, wenn man sich überlegt. Ich habe mal angefangen vor drei Monaten
mit
mit etwas unter fünf Kilometer,
ungefähr knapp neun Minuten den Kilometer.
Und jetzt sind es 10,3 mit 6,34. Geht voll in Ordnung, oder?
Also man könnte sagen, als Ziel vielleicht so
noch sechs Minuten mal irgendwann auf zehn Kilometer. Also mein Rekord ist, mein Rekord ist fünf Kilometer,
glaube 5,33 oder sowas. Irgendwie. Weiß ich gar nicht so genau. Muss ich mal gucken.
5,37 über genau fünf Kilometer, 5,37.
Da bin ich ja fast schneller als du, ja. Aufholchamp. Also fast, fast, fast, ja.
Am Anfang geht es richtig, geht es richtig ab, ja.
Das ging echt voll klar heute. Also das hatte ich auch noch nie. Das war heute das erste Mal,
dass ich gedacht habe, so nach der Hälfte,
das bin gar nicht ich, der rennt. Ich hatte echt das Gefühl, das ist jemand, der voll trainiert ist, der da läuft.
Versteht ihr, was ich meine? Es ist ganz schwer zu beschreiben.
Normalerweise bin ich nach 6,2, wenn ich schnell laufe, bist du ziemlich, ziemlich kaputt.
So, heute bin ich absichtlich nicht so super schnell gerannt.
Und habe gesagt, okay, machen wir es mal, machen wir es mal, machen wir es mal
halbwegs, halbwegs normal. Und halbwegs normal, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das fühlt sich von der Hälfte an
halbwegs normal, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das fühlt sich von der Geschwindigkeit her und vom Schnaufen her ganz gut an,
war halt das hier. Und dann habe ich mir so gedacht, so ey, also jetzt ist fast die normale Strecke rum
und es geht immer noch ohne Probleme.
Und irgendwie habe ich mir gedacht, dann gucken wir doch mal, wie schnell wir 10 Kilometer packen.
Aber ich bin, also ich hätte noch weiter rennen können. Das Ding ist, ich habe es gemerkt,
also das geht dann so über zwei Brücken drüber auf dem Rückweg dann.
Und da habe ich es gemerkt beim Laufen, dass es mir neben dem Knie anfängt ein bisschen zu ziehen.
So, da habe ich mir gedacht, weißt du was, du hast die 10 Kilometer, schaffst du eh locker,
läufst dir direkt heim, anstatt nochmal die eine Schleife.
Also die normale Runde wäre glaube ich 11,3 oder 11,4 gewesen.
Aber nachdem ich es gemerkt habe, nachdem ich schon bei 8, 8,5 oder so gemerkt habe,
dass es mir ein bisschen rechts im Knie zieht, habe ich mir gedacht, okay, weißt du was,
es kommt ja nicht darauf an, übertreib es mal nicht, lauf einfach direkt heim.
Und dann ist das bei rausgekommen. Also es ist unglaublich, heute ist wirklich ein richtig guter Tag gewesen.
Ich bin nicht im Arsch. Normalerweise, also ohne Scheiß, vor drei Monaten,
wäre ich das im Leben nicht gelaufen und wenn ich gelaufen wäre, hättest du mich danach beerdigen können.
Und es ist nicht so schlimm. Ich bin weder großartig aus der Puste, noch ultra geschafft,
noch denke ich, boah Alter, heute kannst du dich den ganzen Tag nicht mehr bewegen.
Okay, ich weiß jetzt schon, in den Beinen und in den Knien und so,
wird das auf jeden Fall die nächsten paar Stunden und morgen schon sich bemerkbar machen.
Wir machen die Runde, aber es ist nicht so schlimm.
Gerade im Schienbein merke ich das immer. Ich bin jetzt dazu übergegangen,
wenn es Brücken runter geht, die recht steil sind, die laufe ich runter,
weil das geht mir übelst krass aufs Schienbein, wenn ich bergrunter renne.
Ich meine, ich wiege immer noch 90 Kilo, 91 Kilo und wenn du da so steile Brücke,
das sind ja teilweise schon so 15% runter, so für, keine Ahnung, 50 Meter, so 15% Gefälle
und das geht übelst aufs Schienbein. Mein Knie juckt das nicht, das geht mir voll aufs Schienbein
und das merke ich auch, wenn ich dann so über das Schienbein reibe mit der Hand,
dann tut das weh einen Tag danach und wenn ich einfach Abhänge runterlaufe,
1,74, wenn ich Abhänge einfach so, so kurze steile Gefälle, wenn ich die einfach normal runterlaufe,
das dauert jetzt auch nicht so viel länger, man kann sich kurz ein bisschen durchschnaufen
und das geht bei weitem nicht so sehr aufs Schienbein.
Also ob das stimmt, Chatge, was meint ihr, wie genau solche Berechnungen sind?
Ich denke ja nicht, also gerade, also meine, also die Garmin Uhr, die ich anhabe,
das ist ziemlich, ziemlich, naja, was das angeht, also die ist ja auch der Meinung,
passt mal auf, ich sage euch das mal, die ist auch der Meinung, ich bin durchschnittliche Power,
340 Watt habe ich gelaufen, so, jetzt passt mal auf, wenn ich auf meinem Fahrrad,
auf meinem Trainer sitze, da kann ich mit Ach und Krach 150, 160, 170,
wenn ich es richtig übertreibe, 180 Watt mal eine Weile durchgehend treten,
dann ist es vorbei, also das glaube ich meiner Garmin Uhr im Leben nicht,
dass ich beim Rennen 340 Watt laufe, im Durchschnitt, also keine Ahnung,
also keine Ahnung, was das Ding da ausrechnet und dementsprechend glaube ich auch nicht,
glaube ich auch, ne, ne, es war, es war, also es war kaum Rückenwind,
es war auf der Brücke ein bisschen Gegenwind, es war eigentlich relativ windfrei,
würde ich sagen, ab und zu mal ein bisschen von der Seite und so, ne,
also ich hatte, ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ich übelst Rückenwind habe,
also jetzt nicht, weil ich Winter hatte, sondern heute ging es echt, echt staunlich gut,
ging es heute, aber gucken wir uns mal die Fit-Up-Trends an,
ne, es ging wirklich, es ging wirklich erstaunlich gut, aber ohne Scheiß,
selbst wenn es nur 500 Kalorien sind, ist es immer noch nice,
weil 500 Kalorien, da kann ich erstmal eine Runde Nudeln mit Lachs fressen nachher,
ja, das ist schon klar, berghoch, berghoch ist immer was anderes,
ich habe das mal ausprobiert, gibt hier in der Nähe, kennt ihr die steilste Straße von Hessen?
Die steilste Straße von Hessen, das ist in Gelnhausen ist das,
äh, nein, steilste Straßen der Welt, äh, Gelnhausen,
so und die ist glaube ich 28, 28% oder sowas, ja, 27, hier guckt, 27%,
in Gelnhausen, da geht es übelst steil hoch, und ich bin mal was ähnliches hochgerannt,
das sind es aber nur 22%, und Leute, ich dachte mir, als ich unten stand,
aber das geht ein Stück, das geht fast einen Kilometer berghoch,
am Anfang 22%, danach vielleicht noch 18% oder so,
und Leute, ich stehe da unten und denke mir so,
ah ja, easy, so einen Kilometer mal volle Pulle, gar kein Problem, ohne Scheiß,
ich bin 150 Meter gerannt oder konnte ich nicht mehr,
berghoch, ich bin losgelaufen und ich habe quasi beim Loslaufen schon gemerkt,
Alter, direkt 180 Puls oder sowas gab, Alter, ich bin gerade mal 100 Kilometer weiter gelaufen,
gerade mal 100 Meter weiter gelaufen, ich kipp gleich um,
ich habe dann versucht noch langsamer zu rennen, aber wenn du einmal so direkt,
bevor du am Umfall bist, geht gar nicht, also das ging nicht wirklich,
ich bin dann ganz langsam hochgelaufen, so irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
so irgendwie 12 Minuten den Kilometer oder sowas, super langsam hoch,
langsam hoch, da ging das halbwegs, also berghoch, also gerade so 20% plus,
das unterschätzt man, wenn man sich so denkt, easy, ein paar hundert Meter,
ne, ne, genauso wie mit dem Fahrrad, die 16% Steigung ein paar hundert Meter,
Alter, da denkst du auch, du kippst gleich um, naja gut,
ich muss noch kurz ein Package-Update machen, ja, es gibt in Frankfurt,
es gibt in Frankfurt einmal im Jahr, ich glaube Skyrun heißt das, nicht Skyrim,
das ist YouTube, ne Quatsch, Google, da geht es den Messeturm hoch,
1200 Stufen, 222 Höhenmeter und die machen das nicht nur einmal,
das gibt dann irgendwie auch so einen, so einen, so einen, weiß nicht wie das,
die laufen das dann mehrfach und sowas, ganz abgedrehter Shit,
ja Treppe laufen ist, aber mein Finger tut immer noch übelst weh von gestern,
müssen wir unter das Pflaster gucken, ob das jetzt ein bisschen geheilt ist oder nicht,
ich hab mir doch, ich hab mir doch gestern, als ich versucht hab,
einen Sensor zu öffnen, mit dem Finger geschnitten, mit, mit, naja,
es ist nicht wirklich ein Messer gewesen, aber sagen wir mal so,
es hat ein, hat ein langes Metallteil dran, das ist so ein Teil,
was extra zum, zum, zum Öffnen von so kleinem Zeug gedacht ist,
bin ich dann abgerutscht, hab mir oben den Finger geschnitten
und das ist halt auch recht tief gewesen, deswegen, es tut immer noch ein bisschen weh,
ich hoffe, hoffe das ist alles wieder gut zusammengewachsen,
ähm, ich kann, hab ich jetzt eigentlich Package-Updates gemacht oder nicht,
wieder nicht aufgepasst, ich mach das schon so automatisch mittlerweile,
was, was ist, JDK Open JDK und JRE Open JDK are in Konflikt,
Java, da weißt du, da weißt du schon Bescheid, Alter,
heute Abend Powerwolf Konzert, Prog, ja da hab ich, ist in Frankfurt, ne,
oder, Leipzig, ne, Leipzig, weil in Frank, in Frankfurt,
in Frankfurt sind, ist auch, in Frankfurt sind die auch,
ähm, das ist eigentlich voll okay, 66 Euro, wenn ich mir das grad so anguck,
66 Euro pro Karte geht, geht eigentlich echt klar,
so, was mach ich denn jetzt, wahrscheinlich würde ich jetzt erstmal,
okay, was, was hat, J, JRE Open JDK und was ist in Konflikt,
Alter, Java-Shit, man, ich aninstalle einfach alles, ja, easy,
ah, yes, und jetzt Open JDK, äh, was installier ich denn jetzt,
Open JDK oder J, JRE, was installier ich denn jetzt eigentlich,
Open JDK, okay, ach, deswegen waren die in Konflikt oder so,
Java-Zeug, man, äh, kein LTS, wir machen hier Pleading Edge,
Arch by the Way, heute Abend Prager angesagt bei dir,
hast du am Anfang auch eine Laufanalyse machen, machen lassen,
oder hast du irgendwelche Schuhe, ich hab keine Laufanalyse machen lassen,
Schuhe hab ich, das Ding hier, oh, hat das jetzt funktioniert,
Baggage Updates, toll, komm hier, Icons auch noch updaten,
das Teil hab ich zum Rennen, das ist sehr angenehm über längere Strecken,
weil das sehr schön gedämpft ist, ich hab zwei, ich hab einmal welche,
die ich anziehe, wenn ich besonders gerade laufen will, mal,
weil mir die Füße wehtun, und welche, die besonders gedämpft sind,
wenn es nicht so auf die Gelenke gehen soll, was, echt, Arch Linux,
Arch Linux, OpenJDK, was, wie, ne, wo stand da was, News, ernsthaft,
da gab es News zu, wo jetzt, wie jetzt, hier drinne, oder wie,
Arch Linux, oh, da stand wirklich was, ernsthaft, News, äh, ja,
ach hier, Incoming Changes, tatsächlich, wie ist der Chat einfach mal wieder weiß,
alter, der Max, der Max lacked critical information,
we are introducing a change in JDK JRE packages, this is triggered for the way,
okay, instead of having JDK and coexists on the same package,
includes the runtime, okay, na gut, wir haben es richtig gemacht,
wir haben es richtig gemacht, wir haben JDK installiert,
oh, alles gut, Pogu, würde ich sagen, nice, oh, Reboot,
ja, gut zu wissen, aber wir haben es, wir haben es ja richtig gemacht,
so, während das rebootet, gucken wir gerade mal die News an,
uns auf GitHub, was die Woche trendet, ob da irgendwas Spannendes dabei ist,
okay, AI, juckt mich nicht, Singbox, klingt nach nem China-Chinesen-Firewall-Proxy,
oder, wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht, was, ich weiß ja auch nicht,
ob ich mich traue, die Seite aufzumachen, doch, ja, was, was, was proxied das,
ich benutze überhaupt keine RSS-Feeds, also, was bin ich, was bin ich hier sehend,
was macht man damit, gibt's da vielleicht irgendwie FAQ, wofür ist das,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wofür das gut ist, also, ja, Proxy,
aber Anwendungszweck konkret, Universal Proxy Platform,
ja, okay, was auch immer, Hacker-Tools hier, Hyper-Switch, Rust,
Placingly Fast, das muss da doch in der Readme stehen, oder, Placing,
warum steht da nicht Placingly Fast drin, aber wenigstens in den Issues irgendwo,
Placingly Fast, na, wenigstens taucht in den Issues mal Placingly Fast auf,
weil es gibt kein Rust-Projekt, wo nix von Placingly Fast drin auftaucht,
sag mal, Elect Voter Phone gerade, Yep Clock, ne, machten sie nicht,
machten sie nicht, das ist ja cool, gibt's hier sowas wie Street,
Tempo, Tempo, haben wir noch, what, what the fuck,
wie hab ich das gerade geöffnet, Windows, welchen Shortcut hab ich gerade
aus Versehen gedrückt, okay, irgendwelches AI-Gedöns,
Kubernetes, beziehungsweise Container-Kram, vermute ich mal anhand der Beschreibung,
React, Telegram Desktop, Python Code Formatter,
Lightning Fast and Powerful Code Editor written in Rust,
ja, die Welt hat unbedingt noch mehr, noch mehr Code Editors gebraucht,
aber der ist besser, weil der ist Placingly Fast,
nein, sorry Leute, der ist Lightning Fast, Placingly Fast war dem auch zu ausgeleiert,
wieder so ein Projekt, wo keiner weiß, wie man es richtig ausspricht,
deswegen muss es Labs, oh na, nix sonderlich Spannendes dabei,
gibt es auch langsame Texteditoren, ja, Word zum Beispiel,
kennst du dich mit Keycloak aus, ne, ich weiß was es ist,
aber ich hab's nie groß verwendet, bei der alten Firma, wo ich gearbeitet hab,
da hatten wir einen Keycloak, frag mich nicht mehr für was,
ich glaube für Active Directory Authentifizierung,
ohne Active Directory Authentifizierung machen zu wollen,
das hat sich irgendwie Active Directory Credentials gesüngt,
und dann haben die irgendwie OAuth gegen Keycloak oder so gemacht,
ganz wirres Zeug, ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern,
hab ich aber nie benutzt, großartig, ich weiß, dass wir das hatten,
und ich war sicherlich auch mal eingeloggen, hab's neu gestartet oder so,
aber nichts, wo ich mich großartig mit auskennen würde.
Progu, na dann, GLHF, muss ja nicht gleich Bestzeit sein,
kannst ja gucken, ob du meins packst, meins wirst du auf die Reihe kriegen.
Aber wenn du 6 Wochen Pause machen musstest wegen Fahrradunfall,
da hat's dich deutlich mehr erwischt als mich beim Fahrradunfall,
du hast ja erzählt, du hast dir sogar die Schulter ausgekugelt und sowas.
Wie findest du das Wort Thumbnail für den Stream gestern?
Das ist alles AI-generated Thumbnails, oder?
Ach hier.
Warum haben wir hier einen Comic Elrecitas auf einmal als Thumbnail?
Ist das wirklich AI-generated? Das ist richtig gut, ey.
Das ist richtig gutes Thumbnail, ey.
Das könnt ihr ruhig, also, das sind Thumbnails,
das sind Thumbnails, wir haben auch noch einen YouTube-Archiv,
da könnt ihr die Thumbnails ruhig mitzünden.
Das ist mega nice, sind die.
Das Thumbnail von gestern hat halt mal so gar nichts mit dem Streaminhalt zu tun, ja?
Oder ist das, oder analysiert der auch, was ich sage in dem Stream?
Oder wirklich nur der Titel?
Ach so, ach, du hast das verstanden.
Das ist richtig nice, ja.
Das ist das beste Clickbait-Thumbnail überhaupt, Alter.
Das könnte man glatt für irgendein Video verwenden, man.
Richtig, richtig nice.
Extremly Pog.
So.
Warum ist hier irgendwie der Teufel, oder so, bei Ubuntu 23.10?
Richtig nice.
Ah, FireFat.
Okay.
Let's go.
Was können wir uns denn auf YouTube antun heute?
Chrome's neue Werbeeinstellung.
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Google Chrome.
I quit Kobol.
Gute Idee.
17 gruselige Automatisierungsideen.
Ah, das gucken wir nachher.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, sogar schon auf.
Das ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig spannend.
Chillen an der Straße.
Relax-Bänke in Erfurt.
Aha.
Die IT eines Open-Source-Startup-Unternehmens.
Ja.
Okay.
Kann man das hier nicht bewegen?
Gibts nicht.
Outdated, outdated, overrated, debated.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Ist das Seins, oder ist das seine Firma, oder?
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Gucken wir uns das doch an.
Smart Home Inspiration 26.
Hm.
Was?
We hacked Apple's find my net.
Ach, komm.
Ich habe mittlerweile kein CT-3003-Dings-Video mehr geguckt.
Mal gucken, ob das was taugt.
Internet Historian.
Den gucke ich auch immer gerne.
Warum Windows 10 bald zum Problem wird.
Naja, wisst ihr warum?
Wahrscheinlich, weil Windows 10-Support bald abläuft, oder?
Ich habe irgendwo gelesen,
dass Windows 10 die letzte Version von Windows ist.
Ja, das stimmt ja so überhaupt nicht.
Also, da kann man sich drüber streiten,
ob es jetzt stimmt oder nicht.
Microsoft hat natürlich auch ein bisschen zu wenig dagegen gesagt.
Das kam aus dem Microsoft-Umfeld.
Und Microsoft hat es halt mal so stehen lassen.
Windows 10-Support endet am 31.12.2024.
Ja, ist nur noch ein Jahr hin, ne?
Muss man sich mal überlegen.
Hält sich in Grenzen.
Also, es ist wirklich...
Habt ihr nicht auch?
Also, ich gehe davon aus, dass er...
Ja, hier.
Ne?
Dass er das Support-Ende meint.
Das war irgendwie klar.
Da müssen wir wahrscheinlich das Wettkampf nicht gucken.
Die Leute sind so cringe, Alter.
So cringe.
Die Microsoft-Matrix.
Oh, Leute.
Ich bin kein großer Microsoft-Fan.
Aber das schmerzt einfach.
Das sind genauso die Leute immer.
Mini-weiche Windows früher.
Ah, das tut so weh, ey.
Okay, komm.
Wir skippen mal schnell.
Wir skippen mal schnell über das Video drüber.
Und dann gucken wir uns an...
...was sie getrieben haben mit dem Apple Find Me.
Irgendwo gelesen, dass Windows 10 die letzte Version von Windows sein wird.
Das liegt daran, dass viele Medien lieber Unwahrheiten als Clickbait veröffentlichen,
nicht mehr anständig recherchieren und dann auch noch zu stolz sind, um ihre Fehler zu beurteilen.
Das stimmt wohl.
Zumal...
Das ist so eine typische...
...richtige Halbwahrheit.
Mit diesem Windows 10 wird das letzte Windows, was es je geben soll.
Das stimmt und stimmt gleichermaßen nicht.
Es wurde nie so richtig offiziell von Microsoft gesagt.
Das hat irgendein Typ, glaube ich, auf...
Keiner aus dem Windows-Team selbst, irgendeiner aus dem Microsoft-Umfeld hat das mal erzählt.
Aber Microsoft hat da schon ziemlich in Kauf genommen und nie was dagegen gesagt.
Aber ausnahmsweise sind diesmal die bösen Journalisten nicht allein schuld daran,
dass dieser Unsinn in vielen unserer Köpfe verankert war.
Der Spruch, Windows 10 wird das letzte Windows sein,
stammt tatsächlich von einem Microsoft-Mitarbeiter,
welcher den Satz im Zuge einer offiziellen Microsoft-Konferenz für Entwickler ausgesprochen hat.
Das ist nicht das, was heute passiert.
Wir veröffentlichen Windows 10, und weil Windows 10 das letzte Version von Windows ist,
arbeiten wir alle noch...
Also die haben das schon absichtlich so stehen lassen.
Und ich meine wirklich alle Medien weltweit sind auf diesen Zug dann aufgesprungen.
Dass er das gesagt hat überhaupt, war allerdings ein Fehler.
Es war nie so vorgesehen, er hätte das wirklich nie sagen sollen.
Und der Mitarbeiter selbst, der das gesagt hat, arbeitet gar nicht im Windows-Team bei Microsoft.
Genau, so habe ich das auch im Hinterkopf.
Hat eigentlich gar nichts mit Windows zu tun, sondern arbeitet mit...
Sag mal, hat der einen übelst dreckigen...
Oder sieht das einfach nur so aus?
...Anderen Unternehmen und Entwicklern zusammen, um sie zu beraten, über Microsofts Cloud-Dienste.
Hier hätten die Medien, die darüber berichtet haben, zumindest stutzig werden sollen.
Warum sagt ein Cloud-Typ von Microsoft solche Dinge über Windows?
Weil er halt einfach random Shit in der Präsentation erzählt hat.
Hat doch gar nichts mit dem System zu tun.
Einen allzu großen Vorwurf will ich den Medien gar nicht machen,
die ohne auch nur eine Minute darüber nachzudenken, die ihren kleinen Bericht verfasst haben.
Siehst du richtig, Mr. Toony.
Wenn euch bei einer Apple-Konferenz zum Beispiel ein Apple-Mitarbeiter sagt,
ihr könnt euer iPhone in der Mikrowelle aufladen,
dann wäre ich auch angepisst, wenn man mir im Apple-Store dann die Garantie verweigert auf mein explodiertes iPhone.
Da ist mir auch ziemlich egal, welcher Mitarbeiter das gesagt hat.
Merkt euch diese Metapher vielleicht für später, die werden wir noch brauchen.
Und obwohl Microsoft diese Aussage von ihrem eigenen Mitarbeiter sofort dementiert hat,
war das nachfolgende Statement nicht wirklich genug, um die Aussage vorzulegen.
Richtig, genau so sehe ich das auch.
Microsoft hätte das ohne Probleme richtigstellen können,
so nach dem Motto, er meinte die letzte Version, also nicht die letzte, die rauskommt,
sondern die aktuellste Version von Windows, ja.
So Last und Latest ist ein bisschen schwierig jetzt das so mit, ne.
Vollständig zu revidieren.
Die jüngsten Kommentare auf der Ignite-Konferenz zu Windows 10 spiegeln die Art und Weise wieder,
wie Windows als Dienst bereitgestellt wird, der fortlaufend neue Innovationen und Updates
mit kontinuierlichem Mehrwert für unsere Privat- und Geschäftskunden bietet.
Blablabla.
Nirgends war auch nur ansatzweise die Rede davon, dass die Aussage auf der Konferenz ganz einfach Bullshit ist.
Ja, wie gesagt, Microsoft hat das absichtlich in Kauf genommen, die fanden das doch gut.
Mit der großartigen Mikrowellen-iPhone-Metapher auszudrücken.
Die Stonks Leute bei Microsoft haben gesagt, lasst es ruhig mal so stehen, da gehen die Leute voll drauf ab.
Jemand bei Apple hat auf der Bühne einen Blödsinn erzählt, aber es hat dabei geholfen mehr iPhones zu verkaufen.
Da war es gar nicht so wichtig, dass es nicht stimmt.
Ja, genau.
Auch ein vages Dementi ist irgendwie ein Dementi.
Und wenn Windows 11 rauskommt, können sie immer noch sagen, ja wieso.
Das hat doch gar keiner so gesagt.
Ich werfe jetzt Microsoft nicht vor, absichtlich das gemacht zu haben.
Natürlich, ich glaube nicht, dass es ursprünglich absichtlich entstanden ist.
Aber ich sehe es ja ähnlich, wie er das auch erzählt hat.
Man hat das absichtlich genutzt, ja.
Ich finde das auch gar nicht verwerflich letztendlich.
Marketingzeug lebt halt durch ein bisschen Bullshit-Gelaber.
Und vor allem immer noch sehr leichtgläubige Leute.
Man hat zweifellos davon profitiert, weil mehr Leute genau deshalb das Upgrade gemacht haben.
Und zweitens hätte man das auch besser kommunizieren können, dass die Aussage in Wahrheit nicht stimmt.
Hier sind zum Beispiel bessere Formulierungen dafür.
Man hätte zum Beispiel einfach sagen können, Windows 10 ist nicht das letzte Windows.
Oder diese Aussage war nicht korrekt.
Ich bin kein Kommunikationsexperte, daher gebe ich diesen Tipp an Microsoft vollkommen honorarfrei.
Dass dies in Microsofts Interesse war, zeigt aber auch die Tatsache,
wie aggressiv Windows 10 als Upgrade für alle Nutzer von Windows 7 und Windows 8.1 vermarktet wurde.
Zuerst hatte Microsoft das kostenlose Upgrade ja
Windows Phone 8.1, MonkaS, Alter.
das insbesondere Windows 7-Nutzern angedreht wurde.
Dann gab es die Get Windows 10 App, auch bekannt als GWX,
welche ständig lästige Upgrade-Erinnerungen für Nutzer älterer Betriebssysteme anzeigte.
Statistiken zeigen, dass das sehr viele Nutzer auch in Anspruch genommen haben.
Microsoft selbst hat sich damit gebrüstet,
dass Windows 10 den schnellsten Gewinn an Marktanteil hatte in der Geschichte des Betriebssystems.
Kein Wunder, wenn 99% der Nutzer bei jedem PC-Start mit einer Pop-Up-Meldung zum Upgrade überredet wurden.
Und als dann Windows 11 angekündigt wurde, war auf einmal alles anders.
Nicht alle Windows 10 Nutzer konnten das Upgrade durchführen.
Ja gut, da haben sie sich ja auch ein bisschen ins Knie geschossen.
Wobei ich echt sagen muss, ich hatte überhaupt keine Probleme auf keinem meiner Rechner.
Hattet ihr Probleme beim Upgrade?
Ich meine, ich habe letztens meinen vorvorletzten Rechner geupgradet,
also Windows 11 installiert, ohne irgendwelche Hacks.
Das war ein Xeon T-Max FPS-Zusammenstellung von 2013.
Ja, die war das und die habe ich upgegradet.
Die habe ich abgegradet, auch wenn Windows 11 ging, ohne Probleme.
Ja, das war ein Xeon. Was hatte ich denn da? Ach, keine Ahnung.
Obwohl sie beim letzten System sprichwörtlich fast schon dazu gezwungen wurden,
durch Meldungen, die eher an ein Virus als an ein kostenloses Angebot erinnern.
Das Upgrade war zwar immer noch kostenlos, aber die Hardwareanforderungen waren jetzt so hoch,
dass praktisch sämtliche Hardware von vor 2017 davon aus...
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ihr im Zweifelsfall mehrfach Windows-Lizenzen kaufen müsst?
Weil es mittlerweile keine CD-Keys in der Form mehr gibt.
Also, wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel eine Windows-Kiste aktiviert habt,
dann ist das erstmal hardwaremäßig bei der Aktivierung an diesen Rechner gebunden.
Ihr könnt das transferieren auf einen anderen Rechner.
Das geht aber meines Wissens nach nur, wenn ihr das Ding vorher
mit einem Microsoft-Account verknüpft habt.
Und dann irgendwie die Lizenz über euren Microsoft-Account auf neuen Rechner transferiert.
Super weird, Champ. Checkt keiner, wie das funktioniert.
Lizenzen transferieren zwischen Rechnern.
Ausgeschlossen. Plötzlich wird jenen Nutzern die 2015 zum Gratis-Upgrade
auf die vermeintlich letzte Version von Windows transferiert.
Ja gut, das Script auf GitHub. Es gibt ja schon seit jeher Trick 17
zum Windows-Aktivieren.
Wenn man das machen will, ist okay, kann man machen.
Aber Microsoft wird sich da...
Also, kann sich ja jeder selbst überlegen.
Aber keine Links-Post, Leute. Sonst MonkaToss...
Es gab für Windows 7 doch auch so einen Bootloader-Patch,
der alte Dell OEM-Zertifikate reingepatcht hat.
Erinnert sich da noch jemand?
Windows 7 konntest du easy as fuck aktivieren mit so nem Mini-Hack, Mini-Crack.
Ich werde jetzt weder Namen noch sonst was nennen.
Aber der eine oder andere erinnert sich vielleicht noch.
Die haben damals geleakte Dell OEM-Zertifikate extrahiert.
Und das wurde dann vor dem Booten quasi an die richtige Stelle in RAM geschrieben,
sodass der Windows-Bootloader dachte, du hast ein Dell-PC oder HP-PC, ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
und ist aktiviert.
...installiert wurden, nur noch als Tipp gegeben, einen neuen PC zu kaufen,
wenn sie die neueste Systemversion benutzen.
Wisst ihr, woran mich das erinnert?
Könnt ihr euch noch... Als Microsoft die Xbox One vorgestellt hat,
da war das... Erinnert euch vielleicht noch an diese Geschichte mit HDMI-Eingang,
HDMI-Ausgang, Baseball-Overlay und sowas, wo die so voll auf TV und Fernsehgeschiss gemacht haben.
Wo sich alle gefragt haben, was zum Teufel, das ist ne Spielekonsole,
was wollt ihr mit diesem komischen Baseball-Football-Scheiß?
Erinnert sich vielleicht noch der eine oder andere.
Und in dem Zuge haben sie ja damals bei der Xbox One-Präsentation erzählt,
dass es auch immer alles always on und nur mit Microsoft-Account
und immer mit Internet verbunden und so sein muss.
Und auf die Frage hin, was denn Leute machen sollen mit der Konsole,
die nicht permanent online sind, hat Microsoft damals gesagt,
ja, das ist toll, dass ihr fragt. Für diese Leute haben wir genau das passende Produkt.
Es heißt Xbox 360.
Irgendwie erinnert mich das ein bisschen dran.
Also Microsoft schießt sich da auch mal ganz gerne mal selbst ins Knie.
Weißt du, die Leute wollen ne Xbox One kaufen, kriegen dann aber gesagt,
nee, kauf dir halt eine Xbox 360, wenn du offline spielen willst.
Dass ihr aktueller Computer für alle modernen Aufgaben des Alltags
immer noch mehr als genügend Leistung bietet und mit Windows 11
weiterhin perfekt laufen würde, ändert für Microsoft nichts an dieser Tatsache.
Und noch dazu wird Windows 10 deutlich früher eingestellt,
als es viele in den USA gemacht hätten.
Die Folgen davon könnten schwerwiegender sein,
als wir das jemals bei irgendeiner vorherigen Windows-Version gesehen haben.
Wisst ihr was, das glaube ich nicht.
Ich denke, es werden zwei Sachen passieren.
Entweder sind genug Leute abgegradet,
oder es gibt einen, sagen wir mal, sehr extended Support-Zeitraum für alle,
für Windows 7.
Äh, nicht Windows 7, Windows 10, nicht Windows 7.
Äh, für Windows 10.
Also sollten, sollten irgendwie 30, 40% der Leute noch auf Windows 10 sein,
wenn Windows 10 eingestellt wird, Support,
dann wird das Microsoft sicherlich nicht die Blöße geben,
gerade auch was Sicherheitssachen angeht,
nachdem sie so hart dran gearbeitet haben,
ihren Ruf zu verbessern die letzten Jahre, was ja auch geklappt hat.
Da einfach harter Cut zu machen, einzustellen,
und auf einmal siehst du nur noch News-Meldungen,
Windows-Leute gehacksort.
Ja, Windows geht auch ohne Aktivierung, ja.
Ja, aber Windows XP ist ja nun wirklich verschwindend gering heutzutage noch.
Guck mal, das war 2014.
... lag der Marktanteil des Betriebssystems bei 29% laut StatCounter.
Nur als Kontext, Windows XP war bis 2012 die meistbenutzte Windows-Version
und wurde erst 10 Jahre nach Release durch Windows 7 eingeholt.
Windows 7 war dann ebenfalls enorm belebt und hatte 60% Marktanteil im Jahr 2015
und zu Support-Ende im Jahr 2020 waren es dann 14%.
2019, also ein Jahr vor dem Support-Ende, waren es immer noch 20%.
Und jetzt zum Vergleich mit Windows XP...
Guck mal, Windows XP hat halt nichts mehr, wie gesagt.
So, und das ist, das ist halt das Ding,
wenn das bis, bis in ein, zwei Jahren noch so aussieht und sei es nur 40%,
dann wird's das mit dem Einstellen so in der Form nicht geben.
Dann wird's ne riesen Offensive geben,
jetzt alle bitte mal kostenlos upgraden, jetzt hier das und jenes
und dann gibt es, dann gibt es Windows 12, was wieder aussieht wie Windows 10
oder IRGENDWAS.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass sie es einfach Hardcard einstellen würden,
weil die haben so hart dran gearbeitet,
ihren Ruf zu verbessern die letzten Jahre, was Sicherheitslücken angeht.
Das hat ja auch geklappt, es gibt ja viel, viel weniger als früher.
Und dann auf einmal würde es ja für die nächsten zwei, drei Jahre explodieren.
Windows 10.
Es ist immerhin noch zwei Jahre bis zum Support-Ende von Windows 10,
aber momentan hält das Betriebssystem laut Statista einen Marktanteil von über 70%.
Sogar Windows XP hatte nur 42%.
Bei macOS gibt's auch ne Versionierung, klar.
Ich glaube, Apple hat's weniger mit Zahlen, mehr mit Namen mittlerweile.
Da gab es ja was, alles Snow Leopard, Big Sur, High Sierra,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie der ganze Krempel eigentlich alles heißt.
Die stehen ja da eher oft, aber das ist da auch so, ja.
Und da haben auch viele das Problem,
dass ältere Macs nur ältere OS-Versionen laufen lassen können.
70% Marktanteil zwei Jahre bevor der Update-Support offiziell eingestellt.
Zu wenig Linux-User, das wundert mich jetzt nicht.
Und 70% ist ein Problem.
Es sind ja Desktop-User in dem Fall.
Denn wenn diese Nutzer nicht bis 2025 entweder ein Update auf Windows 11 machen,
bei Inkompatibilität einen neuen PC kaufen oder bis dahin Linux-Nutzer werden,
dann gibt es für sie voraussichtlich keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr.
Ja, Microsoft wird garantiert in irgendeiner Form darauf reagieren,
wenn das noch so hoch sein wird.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie einen harten Cup machen trotzdem,
wenn das noch 40 plus Prozent benutzen.
Aber vielleicht, Leute, vielleicht ist ja das Linux-Desktops.
Somit könnten Millionen von Nutzern schon in zwei Jahren
mit einem alten und unsicheren Betriebssystem zurückgelassen werden.
Und wie wird Microsoft das lösen?
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Es gibt allerdings eine Reihe von Möglichkeiten, die eintreten können.
Also ich denke, wenn Microsoft drauf guckt und sieht,
fuck, das haben noch 40% Windows 10 und wir schalten in drei Monaten ab,
das ist also spätestens so sein,
die machen Extended-Support für jeden
und sie werden im Vorfeld auf jeden Fall wieder die Gängelungen anziehen
mit jetzt upgraden, jetzt upgraden, jetzt upgraden.
Ja, dann machen sie im Zweifelsfall sowas wie,
wenn ihr jetzt upgradet, bekommt ihr ein halbes Jahr Office 365 dabei
und so weiter und so weiter.
Die werden sich da schon was einfallen lassen.
Vielleicht gibt es auch einen Zwangsupgrade.
Problematisch wird es halt auf allen Kisten,
die nicht upgraden können.
Aber das dürften gar nicht so viele sein.
Und ansonsten vielleicht lockern sie das nochmal,
weil ich davon nicht ausgehe.
Könnten und auch die möchte ich gerne mit euch besprechen.
Die erste und zugegeben nicht ganz unwahrscheinlichste Lösung,
auf die auch Microsoft sicherlich hofft,
ist, dass wir ganz einfach alle bis dahin einen neuen Computer kaufen.
Microsoft hat schon jetzt damit begonnen,
Nutzer vor dem Supportende von Windows 10 zu warnen
und Vollbildmeldungen sogar am Puls.
Ja, Nanomaten auf Windows XP gibt es immer noch, klar.
Viele Nutzer, deren Hardware mit Windows 11 kompatibel ist,
wisst ihr, dieses Hintergrundbild,
das verwirrt mich jedes Mal.
Ich finde, das sieht aus wie Kompatibilität.
Ich finde, das sieht aus wie komisch gefärbte Pringles-Chips.
Kennt ihr nicht auch, dieses Ding hier?
Das sieht original aus wie Pringles.
Also, Pringles, als ich die zum letzten Mal gegessen habe,
das ist schon 15 Jahre her, aber da sahen die noch so aus.
Mittlerweile sind die wahrscheinlich kleine
und nur noch die Hälfte in einer gleich großen Packung drin.
...kompatibel ist, dürfen sich spätestens dann
von Windows 10 verabschieden und eben die neuen.
Du sollst dich immer ans Essen denken.
Leute, ich habe heute Poggers.
Also, guckt mal.
Ich habe heute 890 Kalorien verbraucht.
Ich kann fressen, so viel ich will.
...beste Version installieren.
Jetzt schon.
All jene, deren Computer nicht mit Windows 11 kompatibel sind,
werden sich dann einfach einen neuen Computer kaufen
mit Windows 11 oder möglicherweise bis dahin sogar Windows 12.
Das ist sicherlich Microsofts große Hoffnung
und auch die PC-Hersteller dürften sich sehr darüber freuen.
Die Frage ist aber nur, ist das wirklich realistisch?
Nö.
Nun, witzigerweise ja.
Was?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das realistisch ist,
dass die ganzen Leute mit irgendwelchen komischen Laptops
und ollen PCs, die überhaupt nicht technikaffin sind,
solange das gut funktioniert, irgendwie upgraden.
Bevor Covid für einen riesigen Boom im PC-Markt gesorgt hatte,
zeigte die Branche im Jahr 2019 erste Lebenszeichen.
Erstmals seit 2012 ist der PC-Markt im Jahr 2019...
Ja, weil die Leute Homeoffice gemacht haben.
Die Leute mussten sich neue Kisten kaufen während Corona.
Ich meine, da ist ja der Anteil der Homeofficer...
Im gleichen Zeitraum ist auch der Energieverbrauch
und Heizungsverbrauch und so übelst gestiegen bei den Leuten,
weil die mehr daheim sind.
Und warum?
Bingo!
Das Windows 7-Supportende wurde angekündigt.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Also, das glaube ich nicht.
Also, meiner Meinung nach.
Okay, vielleicht spielt das mit rein.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das klingt eindeutig
mehr nach Corona, oder?
Wobei, wann war denn Corona?
2019 oder 2020?
Wann war die erste Corona Homeoffice?
2020? Ah ja.
Okay, dann war das vielleicht doch Windows 7.
Ein Jahr später haben wir bestimmt auch viele nochmal gekauft,
wegen Homeoffice.
Wenn eine Scary-Meldung von Microsoft
auf dem Desktop von Millionen von Leuten aufscheint,
die ihnen sagt, dein PC ist zu alt
und du musst einen neuen kaufen,
denken extrem viele Leute gar nicht nach,
gehen ins nächste Technische
und kaufen einfach einen neuen Computer.
Hat übrigens ein sehr nices T-Shirt.
Der beste Beweis dafür ist genau das Supportende von Windows 7.
Damals war sogar das kostenlose Upgrade von Windows 7 auf Windows 10
immer noch möglich,
aber als das Supportende auf dem Desktop vieler Nutzer aufschien,
sind PC-Verkäufe weltweit zwischen 2,7 und 4,8 Prozent.
Das Upgrade ist heute noch möglich.
Du kannst, glaube ich, heute noch,
wenn du einen gültigen Windows 7 Key hast,
kannst du den, glaube ich, heute noch aktivieren,
für Windows 11.
Und nochmal, das erste Mal seit sieben Jahren damals.
Microsoft und die PC-Hersteller
hoffen sehr wahrscheinlich diesmal auf einen noch stärkeren Effekt.
Jene Nutzer, die ihre PCs schon damals
von Windows 7 auf Windows 10 upgradet haben,
Ach, das geht nicht mehr?
haben nun noch ältere Hardware
und da wird es eine höhere Bereitschaft geben,
diese durch ein Neugerät zu ersetzen.
Der Effekt könnte noch weiter verstärkt werden
durch den Release von Windows 12.
Moment, hat er da gerade keine Hose angehabt?
Neugerät zu ersetzen.
Der Effekt könnte noch weiter verstärkt werden.
Ach nee, okay.
Er hatte eine hell... ah, okay.
Ich dachte gerade,
er ist nackig aufgestanden hintergrund.
Durch den Release von Windows 12.
Wenn da Nutzer denken,
mein PC ist ja jetzt schon zwei Versionen hinten,
jetzt muss aber echt mal ein neuer her.
Ob das aber reichen wird,
wenn am Supportende von Windows 10
alle Nutzer umsteigen,
das bezweifle ich ganz ehrlich.
Viele, und dazu zähle ich mich ganz ehrlich selbst auch,
haben kein Verständnis dafür,
dass alte, aber immer noch gut funktionierende Hardware
wegen eines Software-Updates weggeschmissen wird.
Das Jahr des Linux-Desktops, Leute.
Eine andere Möglichkeit,
die Microsoft eventuell in Betracht ziehen wird,
ist einfach den Support-Zeitraum von Windows 10 zu verlängern.
Da tippe ich ja persönlich drauf.
Und ich denke,
Microsoft könnte fast gezwungen sein, dies zu tun,
ohne dass sich Millionen von Nutzern
einfach das Update verweigern.
Die Frage wird natürlich sein,
ist Microsoft wirklich bereit,
Millionen von Nutzern
und die aktuell beliebteste Windows-Version
einfach so ohne jegliche Sicherheits-Updates zurückzulassen?
Ich bezweifle es ganz ehrlich,
angesichts dessen,
dass es für Windows XP und auch für Windows 7
einen erweiterten Support-Zeitraum gab.
Aber versprechen kann ich es nicht.
Microsoft zeigte sich zwar immer wieder in der Vergangenheit
gutmütig mit seinen Updates
und hat zum Beispiel sogar 2019
das Update für Windows 10 geändert,
da es von einer schwerwiegenden Sicherheitslücke betroffen war.
Wenn der Maklenteil von Windows 10
auch im Jahr 2025 noch höher ist als der von Windows 11,
glaube ich ernsthaft,
dass ESU-Updates auch darüber hinaus noch angeboten werden.
Ja, ich auch.
Aber darauf wetten würde ich nicht.
Ich tippe da aber auch drauf.
Vor allem durch das transalierte Gratis-Update,
aber auch durch die vermeintlichen Versprechen,
es sei die letzte Version von Windows,
viele der Probleme vom Support-Ende von Windows 7 geerbt.
Probleme, die sehr wahrscheinlich
sogar von Zauberhand verschwinden werden.
Hunderte Millionen von Nutzern sind betroffen
und deren PCs werden sich auch 2025
nicht einfach in Luft auflösen,
wenn sie die Systemanforderungen von Windows 11
Wupp, wupp, pet
nicht erfüllen.
Immerhin gibt es aber etwas Licht am Ende des Tunnels
und laut einer Analyse von über 10 Millionen PCs,
die vorrangig im Unternehmen benutzt werden,
sind knapp 45% der aktuellen Geräte mit Windows 11 kompatibel.
Das bedeutet, dass immerhin
Hast du schon Nubara-Linux getestet?
Nee.
Was ist da der, der, der, ja,
das, das Alleinstellungsmerkmal,
warum man das verwenden soll?
Recht viele PCs das System schon jetzt installieren können.
Ragman, ich hab einfach Private Messages aus.
Ob wir diese Zahlen aus dem Unternehmensbereich,
aber auch auf das Privatkundensegment übernehmen können,
ist allerdings eine andere Frage,
denn Firmen ersetzen ihre PCs im Regelfall etwas häufiger.
Also bei uns auf der Arbeit weiß ich,
die tun sich echt schwer mit Windows 11 Upgrade.
Es wird wahrscheinlich darauf rauslaufen,
dass wir alle ein neues Notebook bekommen,
was ich nice finde.
Ich hab jetzt schon ein fettes Notebook,
da krieg ich noch ein fetteres Notebook,
was aber auch notwendig ist für die 32 Viren Scanner
und Security Tools im Hintergrund.
Gaming-Fokus.
Achso.
Ja, bringt mir nix.
Das bringt mir in RVM, bringt es ja gar nix.
Und für meinen Emulatorzeugen,
unter Linux hab ich meinen Batocera-Mini-PC
und den Rest,
Desktop, Windows und Linux halt,
Parallel und zum Spielen Windows.
Brauch ich nicht.
Ein Upgrade von Windows 10 auf Windows 11 ...
Weil besser als unter Windows wird's nicht laufen.
... durchführen können,
den würde ich es momentan ganz ehrlich auch empfehlen.
Windows 11 ist mittlerweile ein funktionales,
schönes und ausgereiftes System,
das insbesondere im Vergleich zu Windows 10
nicht mehr wie ein Monetarisierungsexperiment wirkt.
Äh ...
Naja, dafür ...
Ja, also Windows 11 ist auf jeden Fall etwas einheitlicher
als Windows 10,
hat aber auch wieder so typischen Microsoft-Abfuck.
Ja?
Zum Beispiel das hier.
Oder das hier.
Und bestimmt noch mehr.
Und mein Lieblingsding, wo man sieht,
dass Windows im Kern immer noch das gleiche ist
wie Windows 3.11,
also bei manchen Sachen,
das hier.
Ihr wolltet schon immer mal diese Icons haben,
oder?
Hi-Res!
Hi-Res-Stern!
Wisst ihr, jede publische Linux-Distro
bringt ein ordentliches Icon-Set mit,
Windows 11 nicht.
Dennis, danke für den Sub.
Das Experiment ist abgeschlossen
und die Monetarisierung durch Werbung bleibt.
Wer hingegen keinen kompatiblen PC hat
und diesen nach 2025 noch behalten möchte ...
Sind Legacy-Icons.
Ja gut, wenn das Legacy-Icons sind,
dann ist die Frage,
wo sind denn die neuen Icons?
Scheint es ja nicht zu geben.
... sollte Windows 11 trotzdem installieren.
Wenn ihr einen 64-Bit-Prozessor,
mehr als 4 GB RAM
und eine SSD in eurem System habt,
dürfte Windows 11 im Grunde
genauso gut wie Windows 10 laufen.
Es ergibt keinen Sinn,
einen immer noch guten i7-7700K wegzuwerfen,
nur weil Microsoft findet,
der Prozessor ist zu alt.
Ist er nicht,
ich habe einen Laptop mit einem Core i5-7200U
mit Windows 11
und der läuft genauso wie mit Windows 10.
Ich glaube auch.
Wenn es um noch ältere Hardware geht,
die aber weiterhin aktiv verwendet wird,
kann ich ehrlich gesagt nur raten,
Linux zu installieren,
denn warum auch nicht?
Linux bietet großartige Kompatibilität
mit älterer Hardware,
bietet für alltägliche E-Mail-
und Browseraufgaben genügend ...
Dann Arch Linux i3 drauf.
Das, was direkt jeden 0815-Casual-Noob
komplett verwirrt,
weil er nicht mal weiß,
wie er einen Firefox aufkriegt.
Man kann auch Linux Mint draufhauen
oder Ubuntu und gut ist.
... großartige Apps und Programme
und viele Distros erfordern auch
keine wirkliche Umgewöhnung von Windows.
Für ganz simple ...
Das sehe ich anders.
Ja gut, wenn man einfach nur
einen Browser aufhat
und alles im Browser macht,
dann natürlich nicht.
Das ist ja der Anwendungsfeld von vielen.
Viele haben halt einfach
Desktop-Arm, Browser auf, fertig.
Vielleicht haben sie noch
ein bisschen mehr Wissen,
um es zuverlässig als Alltagsmaschine
betreiben zu können.
Und ganz ehrlich,
wenn ihr euch nicht mit Windows 11
und potenziellen Update-Blockaden,
manuellen Updates und solchen Dingen
rumplagen wollt auf älterer Hardware,
die ihr wahrscheinlich ohnehin
nur für Office und Browser benutzt,
sind Ubuntu, Fedora und PopOS
wundervolle Alternativen,
die auch perfekt auf älterer Hardware laufen.
Was auch immer passiert,
der Umgang mit dem Support-Ende
der heutigen schnelllebigen Technologie.
Wartungsmanagement.
Und es wird einen Plan brauchen.
Ach ja, by the way,
wenn ich diese komischen Funktionen da sehe,
benutzt irgendjemand von euch
unter Windows,
Moment, Moment, Moment,
Taskbar, Settings, Widgets,
benutzt irgendjemand von euch Widgets?
Den Scheiß verwendet niemand, oder?
Absolut niemand.
Und vor allem, was ein Schwachsinn, Alter!
Simone Tomala.
Eins mit der Natur.
Unten ohne zeigt sie sich im Sand.
Wen zum Teufel interessiert's, Mann?
Alter!
Okay, das einzig Interessante ist tatsächlich,
Traffic-Incidents in der Nähe von Hanau.
Okay, ja, nice.
Das ist so hardcore sinnlos,
dieses Widget-Ding.
Oh.
... passieren wird,
die ein veraltetes System haben,
aber ihren Computer einfach nicht ersetzen wollen.
Es ist nicht im besten Interesse von Microsoft,
dass so eine große Nutzerbasis
auf einem veralteten und unsicheren Betriebssystem
zurückgelassen wird.
Für uns Nutzer bleibt zu hoffen,
dass Microsoft eine Lösung findet,
die für alle passt,
sei es durch eine erweiterte Support-Dauer,
großzügige Upgrade-Angebote,
zum Beispiel mit Angeboten
zum Recycling des bestehenden Computers
oder eine Kombination aus beidem.
Ich würde den bestehenden Computer
einfach für was anderes verwenden.
Windows-Area.de zum Beispiel,
und haltet euer Computer auf jeden Fall aktuell.
Euer digitales Leben könnte davon abhängen,
und wie gefährlich es sein kann,
ein nicht länger unterstütztes Betriebssystem zu verwenden,
hat vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
die NotPetya-Strand-Symbole bewiesen.
Da muss man tatsächlich noch mal unterstreichen,
also selbst wenn,
also wenn die wirklich sagen,
uns juckt das nicht,
40 Prozent Windows-User interessieren uns nicht,
wir stellen das ein,
man sollte nicht sagen,
fick dich Microsoft,
ich bleib auf Windows 10.
Also das ist wirklich problematisch.
Spätestens nach ein, zwei Monaten
gibt es bekannte Sicherheitslücken,
die immer größere Kreise ziehen,
und dann hast du gelitten.
Und ich meine,
auch wenn eine Windows-Sicherheitslücke
nicht das Einzige ist,
was relevant ist,
irgendwie muss dir noch einer
an eurer Windows-Kiste drankommen,
oder irgendwelche Anhänge,
oder irgendwelche Downloads,
die dann, ich meine,
erinnert ihr euch noch daran,
dass mal die Thumbnail-Generierung
im Windows Explorer ausgenutzt werden konnte,
mit manipulierten Bildern,
um Malware einzuschleusen und sowas,
so Dinge kommen dann halt laufend,
und werden immer weiter zunehmen,
umso länger das Ding out of support ist.
Also das ist auf Dauer auf jeden Fall
keine Lösung, das so zu lassen.
Die haben relativ viel gemacht,
also Windows an sich ist tatsächlich
eine große Sache.
Es kommt doch so selten,
vergleicht das mal heute mit früher,
wie oft es riesengroße
Windows-Sicherheitslücken gibt.
Ich meine,
erinnert sich noch einer dran,
wie das hieß?
Es gab zu Windows XP-Zeiten mal
diese Geschichte mit,
dass der RPC-Port offen war,
und sobald du deinen Rechner im Internet hast,
hat es drei Minuten gedauert,
bis du irgendeinen Shit auf dem Rechner hattest.
Wie hieß denn das Ding nochmal?
Und sobald man online gegangen ist,
hat es drei Minuten gedauert,
und man hatte irgendwas.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht I love you.
I love you war das per Mail.
Oder ich weiß nicht, ob es RPC-Port war.
Irgendein Port war offen,
für Windows im Internet von außen,
oder Port 445 oder so.
Das war zu Windows XP-Zeiten,
und da hattest du nach drei Minuten
im Durchschnitt online,
hattest du irgendeinen Scheiß
auf dem Rechner drauf.
Ja, ja, das kann sein.
Das war aber Plaster.
Das kann Plaster.
Voll für den Arsch.
Also sowas ist es doch schon wirklich lange nicht mehr.
Gibt es doch gar nicht.
Oder Port 135.
Ja, ja, genau.
Und damals hast du den Rechner
direkt ans Internet gepackt.
Das heißt, du musstest so Zeug
wie Bit Defender Firewall
oder wie hieß dieses Ding,
was man damals immer auf Windows gehauen hat,
dieses Software Firewall,
als Windows Zone,
Zone Alarm.
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Gibt es das noch?
Okay, das gibt es.
Ach, bei Checkpoint ist das mittlerweile, okay.
Ein leichter Gewinner.
Seid ihr sicher,
dass das richtig übersetzt ist?
Ein leichter Gewinner?
Und was sagen sie zu ihrer Software?
Ein leichter Gewinner.
Ja, den Mist gibt es anscheinend immer noch.
Und es gibt anscheinend auch noch Leute,
die diesen Krempel verwenden.
Ja, Zone Alarm und Avira,
das war damals das Ding.
Man hat es damals,
das war noch vor XP SP2
oder XP SP1.
Wann gab es die Firewall,
die XP Firewall?
Zumal die ja mit XP SP Service Pack
auch komplett
das ganze Betriebssystem umgekrempelt haben.
Also das waren noch ganz andere Zeiten
von Windows Lücken.
Black Friday.
Ach, ist das jetzt auch bald wieder?
Amazon Black Friday.
War nicht erst Cyber Week oder sowas?
Nee.
Prime Week war letztens erst.
Oder wie das heißt.
Und dann gibt es noch Cyber Monday
und Black Friday
und Cyber Monday.
Und dann drehen manche Shops
drehen ja komplett durch.
So nach dem Motto
Black Friday,
Black Friday Week
Cyber Monday,
Cyber Monday Week
und ich habe letzten schon irgendwas gesehen.
Black Friday Monat.
Oder Cyber Monday Monat.
Leute,
was kommt als nächstes?
Das komplette Jahr ist jetzt
Cyber Monday Jahr oder was?
Gentoo Users Recompile.
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
What the fuck?
Ist das dumm, Mann.
Also, was guckt man als nächstes an hier?
Ich wollte mir doch Heimautomatisierung angucken.
Ja, Smart Home Inspiration.
Halloween Magic Mirror Sound Motion.
Jawoll, auf geht's.
Smart Mirror ist so ein Ding.
Ich finde es persönlich komplett unsinnig.
Moment, was?
Lichtsteuerung per Excel, Mann.
Alter, da ist aber ein richtig krasser Office Fan, oder?
Das Letzte, worauf ich kommen würde,
ist mein Smart Home über Excel zu steuern.
Ausgabe 21, los geht es.
Und wir fangen heute mit Daniel an.
Der hat Halloween Automation geschickt
und ich will kein Jahr warten, bis ich die recyceln kann.
Das ist ein gutes Stichwort, ne?
Schickt mir gern schon mal eure Weihnachtsautomationen zu.
Vielleicht machen wir dieses Jahr eine Sonderfolge.
Hallo, ich möchte euch heute zeigen,
wie ihr Halloween mit Hausautomation etwas verschönern könnt.
Bei uns?
Ich habe mir extra so Schokoladenlutscher gekauft,
weil die Kinders die letzten Jahre immer zunehmend geklingelt haben.
Dieses Jahr hat nicht einer geklingelt.
Jetzt muss ich die Lutscher selbst futtern.
Jetzt zeige ich euch,
wie ihr aus dem Rasenmäheroboter einen Geist bauen könnt.
Dazu habe ich zwei alte Waschmitteltonnen zusammengeklebt,
oben einen Ball drauf
und dann auf die Klappe des Husqvarna-Mäherobbers
mit Gaffatepe befestigt.
Der hat ja auch gleich den Vorteil,
dass er die Kettensäge schon eingebaut hat.
Vielleicht noch so ein bisschen Blut verteilen.
Einfach einen Laken drüber gelegt.
Das ist eine mega geile Idee.
Das ist ja eine mega...
Wenn man da jetzt noch Beleuchtung drunter machen würde,
wäre das ja Massive Pog.
Ein witziges oder...
Das ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Und schon kann es losgehen.
Um es für die Kinder, die vorbeikommen,
um Süßigkeiten abzustauben etwas gruseliger zu machen,
habe ich aber eine viel bessere Idee.
Und zwar, was ihr dafür benötigt, ist einfach nur...
By the way, Halloween.
Wisst ihr, was ich auf Twitter gesehen habe?
Da haben ein paar Hausbesitzer in den USA,
weil da ist es ja ein riesen Ding.
Ich denke mal, das ist wahrscheinlich das Land,
wo es herkommt, wo es am meisten abgeht.
Da haben ein paar Hausbesitzer ihre Halloween...
Wie heißt denn das?
Diese Töpfe, die die vor der Tür stehen haben, gefilmt.
Und da gab es so ein paar...
Wie nennt man das?
So ein paar Flashmob-mäßig,
die durch die Straßen gezogen sind
und alle Halloween-Boxen geplündert haben.
Da kamen dann...
Jetzt hast du richtig gesehen,
die haben ihren Hauseingang gefilmt.
Und auf einmal kamen innerhalb von 10 Sekunden
20 Leute um die Ecke,
haben ihre Rucksäcke aufgemacht,
den kompletten Inhalt von diesem Halloween-Zeug reingeschmissen.
Und es waren Familien mit Kindern,
mit Opas, mit allem,
wo man denkt, wie assi kann man eigentlich sein.
Rein, und nach 15 Sekunden waren die wieder weg.
Wir rippen alles hier an Halloween-Sachen,
die da so rumstehen.
Ich meine, wie assi kann man eigentlich sein, Mann?
Ja, genau sowas hier.
Chat, genau sowas.
Das ist nicht das, was ich gesehen habe,
aber genau sowas.
Guck dir das an.
Guck dir das an, Mann.
In 15 Sekunden sind die wieder weg.
The fuck?
Alter, wie assi kann man eigentlich sein, Mann?
Niemand kann sich danach mehr was holen.
Bei den Amis könntest du wenigstens noch eine Selbstschussanlage installieren
und sagen, der Typ war auf meinem Grundstück, kein Problem.
Alles auf meinem Grundstück, darf ich abknallen.
Sind halt Amis, das wird bei uns genauso passieren.
Wenn ich mir überlege, hier in Frankfurt im Bahnhofsviertel
stellt einer eine Tonne mit Essen raus,
das wäre instant weg, Alter.
Das würde genau so aussehen.
Das wäre exakt, das ist kein Ami-Ding.
Aber es ist gerade bitter, dass es bei den Amis passiert.
Da ist ja diese ganze Halloween-Sache deutlich verbreiteter
und akzeptierter auch.
Das finde ich richtig assi.
... mit einem Bewegungsmelder gekoppelt,
der am Eingang ist.
Jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst.
Beim Geist haben wir aufgehört.
Ein witziges oder gruseliges Gesicht draufgemalt.
Naja, die Chance, das stand doch überhaupt nicht zur Diskussion jetzt.
Jemand macht sich weniger scheiße, nur weil es nicht überall passiert.
Dass es irgendwie im bayerischen 120-Seelen-Ort
vielleicht nicht so viel passiert, das mag sein.
Um es für die Kinder, die vorbeikommen,
um Süßigkeiten abzustauben, etwas gruseliger zu machen,
habe ich aber eine viel bessere Idee.
Was ihr dafür benötigt, ist einfach nur eine Sonos-Box.
Diese Box wird dann über IP-Synchron mit einem Bewegungsmelder gekoppelt,
der am Eingang ist.
Die Sonos-Box wird in den Busch versteckt.
Schaut, was passiert.
Das ist eine mega Idee, Alter.
Die scheißen sich in die Hose, Mann.
Also, wenn ihr...
Alter, die erschrecken sich des Todes.
Das ist eine geile Idee.
Generell, man muss auch sagen,
das ist vielleicht auch gar keine schlechte Sache,
die man das ganze Jahr über im Garten lassen sollte.
Zum Halloween-Laufen schickt in Zukunft,
packt vielleicht Wechselhosen ein.
Damit es nicht langweilig wird,
lasse ich per Zufall unterschiedliche Sounds abspielen.
Das ist ja geil, Alter.
Sehr gut.
Lohnt sich vielleicht eine kleine Notiz für nächstes Jahr.
Als erstes wird die Sonos-Box geklaut, genau.
Das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen.
Und wenn es nur eine mentale ist.
So, David hat seinen Magic Mirror, also wahrscheinlich Smart Mirror,
geschickt mit Home Assistant Dashboard.
Ich habe zur Zeit schon einen Magic Mirror gebaut.
Und den habe ich jetzt abgegradet,
um ihn als Smart Home Dashboard zu nutzen.
Schon mal eine gute Idee, weil der Magic Mirror an sich
finde ich reichlich useless.
Aber als Dashboard irgendwie in Kombi, vielleicht ganz nice.
So aus, wenn man sich nähert.
Geht eine Hintergrundbeleuchtung an und man sieht hier
zum Beispiel die Temperatur, die Termine.
Aber kann man auch drauf tappen?
Werte aus Home Assistant habe ich mir angezeigt,
von meinem Auto, den Ladezustand zum Beispiel,
oder das Balkonkraftwerk, was das heute produziert hat.
Hier unten gibt es die News.
Wenn ich jetzt hier hochwische, habe ich mich mit Touch abgegradet.
Aber will man Touch-Eingabe auf seinem Spiegel?
Ja, hast du ordentlich Flecken.
Unsere Kinder machen Touch-Eingabe auf dem Spiegel völlig ohne,
dass der was anzeigt.
Okay, das lasse ich mir noch halbwegs gefallen,
das ist ein Gewinn.
Das spannende ist jetzt aber die Integration in Home Assistant.
Das Ganze ist ein iFrame in einem Home Assistant Dashboard.
Deswegen kann ich jetzt hier oben zum Beispiel auf mein Energy Dashboard
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch, aber wie gesagt,
ich habe ja sowas auch im Flurhängen, also kein Magic Mirror,
sondern ein Dashboard auf zwei Fire HD10s, einmal im Erdgeschoss
und einmal im ersten Stock.
Und das finde ich auch super, sowas im Flurhängen zu haben.
Das switcht bei mir immer, wenn es an der Klingel klingelt,
das ist praktisch, aber ich bräuchte es echt nicht als Spiegel.
Ich habe hier ein kleines Dashboard für mein Auto angelegt.
Das ist noch viel zu schlecht zu erkennen und zu dunkel.
Ich kann jetzt hier auch alles mögliche steuern,
zum Beispiel kann man ein bisschen Party im Flur machen
und schon haben wir hier wunderbar Party.
Wichtig, ganz wichtig, mehr FPS im Flur.
Party-Effekte, wer es mag.
Steuerst du damit auch die Selbstschussanlage?
Klar, klappen dreimal drei Armbrüste aus,
dann hat man hier eine kleine Brücke.
Ich mag es, was man auch machen kann.
Hey Siri, Staubsaugen.
Wenn unser Staubsauger-Roboter losfährt,
wird automatisch auf diese Seite geswitcht.
Das finde ich cool, das finde ich cool.
Ein kleines automatisches Umschalten von dem Haus.
Ich verwende aber keinen Staubsauger-Roboter mehr,
deswegen, es wäre cool, hätte ich einen noch.
Also ich habe hier noch einen, aber ich verwende ihn nicht mehr.
Was auch passiert, wenn jetzt unten im Eingangsbereich
sich jemand nähert und klingelt, dann wird geswitcht.
Warum nicht?
Ja, ich hatte einen Roborock S5 oder S55, irgendwie sowas.
Ich glaube, das eine heißt 55 in Asien und 5 in Europa,
wo es das gleiche Gerät ist.
Weil ich einen habe ohne Entleerungsstation
und mich das einfach nur genervt hat.
Du musst eh nach ein paar Mal hin und her fahren,
musst du das Ding entleeren.
Und das braucht auch ewig,
bis es die ganze Wohnung durch hat.
Ganz im Ernst, wenn ich da irgendwie ab und zu mal
mit dem normalen Staubsauger durch die Wohnung flitze,
bin ich in der Viertelstunde fertig,
komme auch einfacher an Stellen,
wo der Roboter nicht so gut rankommt und fertig.
Also es ist viel simpler sogar.
Wir switchen auf unsere Kamera
und wir haben hier einen kleinen Vorschau,
der ist sehr praktiziert.
Zusätzlich habe ich hier noch ein paar kleine Dashboards
für die Temperaturauslastung, Musiksteuerung,
alles mögliche, was man möchte.
Genau, das ist ein E-Arma-Bildschirm mit Touch durch Glas
und ein spezieller Spionspiegel, damit das Ganze funktioniert.
Grundsätzlich finde ich ja smarte Spiegel auch sehr interessant.
Wir haben uns sogar damals,
als wir die Badezimmer hier im Haus neu gemacht haben,
welche Spiegelschränke, die das eingebaut hatten.
Das war ein zweischneidiges Schwert.
Aber so wie du das gemacht hast,
auch vor allem das Standard-Dashboard,
dass man die relevanten Informationen fürs Leben
auf den ersten Blick sieht und dass der sich anpasst,
wenn der Saugroboter fertig ist.
Das finde ich gut. Ich würde mir wahrscheinlich
keinen fertigen Mirror kaufen.
Dann hast du wieder das Ding,
dass der Hersteller nach 1,5 Jahren sagt,
wie weit er ihn in den Raum schicken kann,
dass die Klingel angezeigt wird.
Das ist das Ding, warum ich so etwas nicht sinnvoll finde.
Wenn ich morgens im Bad stehe und da mal in den Spiegel reingucke,
dann brauche ich weder die Uhrzeit noch die Temperatur.
Ich habe das Handy direkt neben mir liegen.
Wenn ich was machen will, sei es Licht, Heizung, irgendwas,
mache ich schnell vom Handy.
Uhrzeit auf dem Handy.
Auf dem Handy muss ich eh gucken, falls ich raus muss,
ob jemand eine Verspätung hat oder irgendwas.
Ich habe da nicht so viel Mehrwert.
Ihr wisst, ich mag so Gadget-Basteleien,
aber da habe ich den Mehrwert für mich noch nicht entdeckt,
was Magic Mirrors angeht.
Das ist schon ziemlich elegant.
Ob ich da groß durch die einzelnen Seiten navigieren würde,
weiß ich nicht. Aber wenn du das Video siehst,
schreib es gerne mal in die Kommentare, wie oft du das machst.
Da dürfte ja der Alarm nie ausgehen.
Ob der Busfahrplan auch immer aktuell anzeigt,
was den Tag ansteht, gerade für die ganze Familie.
Doch, finde ich schon gut. Ich bin interessiert.
Und dann ist da der heutige Sponsor des Videos,
der die Zeche bezahlt, und das ist Soundcore.
Das freut mich tatsächlich.
Ich gucke die Videos gerne, wir lassen jetzt auch mal eine Runde Sellout laufen.
Ich hatte die ja in der Vergangenheit schon ein paar Mal
in meinen Geschenketipps-Videos.
Und jetzt haben sie gerade eben den Motion X500
auch Spatial Audio bietet.
Und der klingt super, gibt zwölf Stunden Musik wieder,
lädt natürlich über USB-C, hat drei Treiber mit 40 Watt,
einen, der für den Raumklang nach oben feuert,
dieses Skylight und bietet ...
Hat das einen Lüfter? Ist das ein Lüfter?
... per LDAC-Codec, was für Lautsprecher in dieser Preisklasse
durchaus ungewöhnlich gut ist. Du kannst ihn mit nach draußen ...
Nee, nee, nee, das ist kein Lüfter.
... nehmen, und wenn er dir mal ins Wasser fällt,
deswegen sieht das aus wie ein Lüfter.
Das Gehäuse ist aus Metall, fühlt sich hochwertig an.
Er ist ganz schick und er klingt schon wirklich gut,
besonders für seinen Preis und seine Größe.
Aber vielleicht sagst du, Andreas, das ist ja alles ganz nett,
aber so klein muss der gar nicht sein.
Ich habe ein bisschen mehr Grundfläche, ich will den gar nicht weit tragen,
vielleicht mal von einem Zimmer ins andere.
Und dafür legt der X600 noch mal eine Schippe drauf.
Auf 50 Watt, fühlt sich mindestens genauso hochwertig an.
Ich würde gerne im Schwimmbad gehen oder so,
aber ich mache kein Picknick.
Und im Schwimmbad gehst du den anderen Leuten damit schön auf den Sack.
Oder in der Bahn erst mal Haftbefehl anmachen.
Göttesstraße, Louis Vuitton-Store, zahl die Kollektion,
barfick aufspotten, so.
Das Einzige, was ich kann von Haftbefehl,
deswegen muss ich das öfters mal zitieren.
... aber sogar noch ein bisschen besser.
Zusätzlich bekommst du hier einen Klinkeneingang,
wenn du diese Funktion aktivierst,
wird jeder Stereosong in Raumklang umgewandelt.
Und das bekommen beide Lautsprecher tatsächlich ziemlich gut hin.
Der Große hat hier noch die Bass-Up-Taste,
um relativ grob in den Equalizer einzugreifen,
den du sonst am Handy auch nach eigenen Wünschen feintunen kannst.
Unglaublich, dass so viele Leute auf geboostetem Bass stehen,
was im Endeffekt nicht dafür sorgt, dass es besser klingt,
sondern dass da eigentlich noch, ja, es sich,
soll ich sagen,
unnatürlicher anhört.
Das Einzige, was es bringt, ist,
vielleicht wenn du super laut hast, dass im Auto anfangen,
Teile zu wackeln, ja.
Also, viele Leute stehen auf Badewannensound.
Ich glaube, besser kann man es nicht beschreiben.
Ich habe da so eine kleine Abneigung dagegen entwickelt,
gegen dieses einfach nur möglichst dumpf und basslastig.
Beide tatsächlich einfach größer als sie sind
und für 169 Euro bzw. 199 Euro
kannst du eigentlich schon nichts falsch machen.
Aber noch richtiger wird es, wenn du dir bis zum 16.11.
für einen Euro satte Rabatte von 40 bzw. 50 Euro
in Gutscheinform sicherst.
Und alles Weitere und die entsprechenden Links
findest du unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Vielen Dank Soundcore für die Unterstützung.
So, dann haben wir wieder Daniel, Rocky Garage.
Es geht vermutlich um den Soundroboter, den wir hier sehen.
Wir schauen mal rein.
Und auch meinen Staubsaugeroboter.
Das sah aber sehr unaufgeräumt aus.
Dafür kommst du gut dran.
Was wichtig ist, wenn das Ding keine Absaugstation hat.
Schick.
Ich persönlich hätte das wahrscheinlich nicht gemacht,
weil ich viel zu faul gewesen wäre,
da überhaupt einen Schreiner zu beauftragen.
Mir ist das Geld nicht wert gewesen wäre
und ich jetzt schlechter drankomme als vorher.
Aber trotzdem tut es definitiv.
Bei der Planung habe ich direkt eine Klappe
für meinen Staubsaugerroboter mit ihm stehen lassen.
Dieser wohnt nun unter der Treppe,
direkt unter meinem Zweitkühlschrank.
Und wenn er nun ausleeren muss, wie kommst du dran?
Und damit er da auch immer wieder rein und rauskommt,
habe ich die Klappe einfach direkt automatisiert,
sodass sie aufgeht, sobald er rauskommt.
Cool ist es.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es so praktisch ist,
aber es ist nice.
Wenn er sich wieder auf den Weg zurückmacht
und angedockt hat, geht dieser auch einfach wieder zu.
Das Ganze funktioniert über einen Wemos D1 Mini.
An dem hängt ein Kippschalter,
der dann entsprechend das Signal gibt.
Der Roboter ist rausgefahren
und der Wemos D1 Mini lässt dann
ein Servo auffahren.
Sobald er wieder gegen den Schalter fährt,
wird das Servo zu und damit auch die Klappe zu.
Das hier ist ein schönes Beispiel für,
warum es nice ist,
wenn man sich ein bisschen mit
Microcontroller-Programmierung beschäftigt hat.
Diese gesamte Sache könntest du super kompakt
und elegant lösen mit einem ESP32,
einem ESP8266.
Da könntest du den Motor anschließen,
den Schalter anschließen,
du könntest es direkt melden lassen
über Wifi per MQTT an dein Home Assistant
und es wäre wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein Ticken günstiger.
Wobei man das immer schwierig sagen kann,
in Materialkosten bestimmt,
aber der Zeitaufwand in der eigenen Firma
sich aus den Fingern zu saugen ist schon ein bisschen höher.
Aber ich glaube, es wäre die stabilere Sache,
die saubere und schönere Lösung.
So geht das natürlich auch, keine Frage.
Das Ganze funktioniert bei dem Servo
mit einem hochprofessionellen Mechanismus,
nämlich über eine Angelschnur.
Man kann es auch mit dem Arduino machen.
Ich persönlich würde den ESP32 nehmen,
weil eingebautes Wifi, und das ist halt extremly POG,
weil da kann er nämlich auch im Home Assistant
direkt anzeigen lassen, Klappe auf, Klappe zu,
das ganze über ein Webinterface und aus Loxon
und mit meinem MDP-Glastaster steuern,
sodass ich den Roboter auch herausfahren kann,
wann eigentlich ich das möchte.
Das ist schon ziemlich gut, den einfach so aus dem Weg zu haben.
Auch das ist eigentlich eine Sache, die ich schon sehr gerne hätte.
Gut, das ist eine Berufskrankheit.
Wobei, plötzlich, weil ich gesagt habe,
die neuen Arduinos haben doch auch Wifi,
es gab doch erst ein paar neue.
Nano, ge? Verwenden mit Wifi.
Zero sind die auf Linux-Basis.
Wie heißen die? Nano, ge?
Pico. Pico, nicht Nano.
Genau, Pico-W.
Habe ich ja auch noch zwei liegen, aber nie verwendet.
Dass ich nicht weiß, wie groß die nächste Absorgstation ist
und man sich da schwer drauf vorbereiten kann,
als jemand, der auch relativ regelmäßig Saugroboter testet.
Aber, wenn du ihn einfach nur benutzt,
das ist schon ziemlich cool, den einfach aus dem Blickfeld zu haben.
Und der fährt das dann auf, fährt, und wenn er reinkommt...
Okay, Moment, Chat, was?
Was hältst du von der Sichtweise?
Die Smart Home Bubble basiert darauf,
dass wenig Arbeit mit wochenlanger Arbeit
in noch weniger Arbeit zu verwandeln
und was schreit mit weniger Arbeit,
zu verwandeln und was schreit mehr danach,
als ein Smart Mirror, der dir den Griff zum Handy spart.
Das ist mir eindeutig zu high IQ für heute Morgen, keine Ahnung.
Fährt er wieder zu.
Solange ist da halt diese Klappe offen,
aber dein Flur sah breit genug aus,
dass man sich da nicht unbedingt das Schienbein blutig schlägt.
Wäre allerdings wieder ein Halloween-Ding.
So, Hagen ist ins Jahr 2021 gekommen.
Schauen wir mal, was er sich hier gebaut hat.
Warum eine Killer-KI über meine Tomaten wacht.
Ich hatte das Problem,
dass ich im Haushalt ein paar Erinnerungen brauche,
um im Alltag nichts zu vergessen.
Aber nicht stumpf per Push-Nachricht aufs Handy,
sondern im richtigen Moment, wenn ich gerade auch zu Hause bin.
Denn ich habe hier auf dem Balkon zum Beispiel ein paar Tomaten stehen
und weil ich es nicht schaffen würde, sie täglich zu gießen,
erledigt das ein Solarbewässerungssystem für mich
und es war leer.
Und was kam mir da in den Sinn?
Weil mein Smart Home von Homematic IP ist,
wollte ich den MP3-Kombi-Signalgeber nutzen.
Aber Pustekuchen, der geht nur an der CCU.
Man konnte die Einplanung nicht noch größer machen.
Angekündigt für mein Access Point, aber das Update kam dann doch nie.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle auf mein Video hinweisen,
wie es mit Ankündigungen von Software-Updates
von Hardware-Herstellern zu halten ist.
Als ich damals mein Fernseher gekauft habe,
ich kann euch nicht sagen, was es für einer ist,
irgendeiner von Sony, haben die auch angekündigt,
dass sie ein Firmware-Update nachliefern werden,
dass eine neuen, wie heißt der Krempel?
Heißt das auch HDR beim Fernseher?
Also größeres Farbspektrum, Farbraum?
Heißt das auch HDR?
Wie heißt denn das beim Fernseher?
Dass Schwarz schwarzer ist und Rot röter
und HDR, ja?
Die haben auch angekündigt, dass die einen neuen HDR-Standard
unterstützen wollen, per Firmware-Update,
das ist mir heute auch nicht gekommen.
Ist das mein Fernseher, Max?
Max, warum weißt du, was ich für ein Fernseher habe,
ist das mein Fernseher?
Das könnte mein Fernseher sein, das sieht auf jeden Fall so aus, ja.
Taylor, moin, auch wieder am Start.
Alter, jetzt will er es aber wissen, ey!
Opto-Copter-Wahrscheinlich, das ist nicht brummt.
Das ist schon ganz cool.
Ich dachte, der klingt wenigstens wie der Computer aus dem Film.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt eine AI,
die die Sprache in der Richtung machen kann.
Das kann ich nicht tun, Dave.
Ich habe das einmal vor Jahren geguckt,
für manches ist es ja der übelste Kultfilm,
ich kann mich ja nicht mehr daran erinnern.
Ich habe das mal vor Jahren geguckt,
das ist ja der übelste Kultfilm,
ich kann mich ja nicht mehr daran erinnern.
Außer, dass eigentlich den ganzen Film über nicht wirklich viel passiert
und es irgendwie langweilig ist und ich nicht verstehen konnte,
warum das so ein krasser Kultfilm ist.
Sehr gut, nervige Smart-Home-Erinnerungen
sind, glaube ich, schon ein wichtiges Ding.
So eine einmalige Benachrichtigung,
wechsel mal die Batterie in irgendeinem Sensor.
Ja, das ist gut.
Oder wenn die Geschirrspülmaschine noch nicht angestellt ist.
Erinnerung, die Spülmaschine muss noch angestellt werden.
Oder die Sensoren zu dem Schluss kommen,
dass gelüftet werden sollte.
Bitte dringend lüften.
Oder die Messsteckdose festgestellt hat.
Die Waschmaschine ist fertig, bitte entleeren.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich, was du meinst.
Ja gut, das ist schon ein bisschen so.
Ich glaube, wer denkt, dass er mit Smart-Home
Zeit und Geld spart, liegt falsch.
Also, du kannst Zeit und Geld sparen,
aber dadurch, dass man
das eher auch als Hobby macht,
ist man trotzdem immer permanent am Basteln.
Also, wenn man sich ganz krass zusammenreißen würde
und sich auf 5, 6 Sachen konzentriert,
die einem den größten Mehrwert bringen
und die, sag mal, die simpelste Lösung dafür baut
und gut ist, und du kannst dann
das dann so stehen lässt, dann kann man vielleicht
Zeit und Geld sparen.
Für viele Leute ist Smart-Home
Hobby und Bastel Spaß in einem,
wo man unendlich viel Zeit reinsenken kann,
weil es Spaß macht.
Da sparst du weder Geld noch Zeit,
aber du freust dich halt umso mehr, wenn es gut funktioniert
und es macht halt auch Spaß zu sehen,
hier könnte man noch was verbessern,
aber der Zeitaufwand zum reinen Nutzen,
wenn man so die reine Automatisierung sieht,
die ist wahrscheinlich relativ gering,
aber der Gewinn ist nicht nur
die Zeitersparnis,
sondern das Gesamtprojekt.
Der Weg ist das Ziel,
beschreibt es wahrscheinlich bei Smart-Home am besten.
Und das Ziel ist nie erreicht.
Oder der Rasenmäher seine Arbeit beginnt.
Oder der Rasenmäher zu seinem geplanten Arbeitsende
nicht wieder in seiner Hütte ist.
Oder es an der Tür klingelt.
Da bekomme ich allerdings auch eine Push-Nachricht,
falls ich gerade im Garten bin.
Weil noch immer Speicherplätze
im Modul frei waren, noch ein paar Infos,
die er zwischendurch mal raushaut.
Es regnet.
Sie haben Post.
Der Sound wird mich so nerven, Mann!
Den Beweis habe ich mir auf dieser Webseite
per kostenlosen Text-to-Speech-Programm generieren lassen.
So, ich hoffe, das war interessant,
und vielleicht hat ja der ein oder andere Bock,
was nachzubauen.
Schon sehr cool, ich verlinke die Sachen zu allen Videos,
die schon ein paar Tage alt sind, schnell wieder ausverkauft sind.
Also, wenn ihr das Video seht und das nachbauen wollt,
zögert nicht zu lange.
Andi hat ein Video geschickt, das schon ein paar Tage alt ist.
Könnte das von deinem Informatiklehrer kommen?
Ja, definitiv, weil dein Informatiklehrer wahrscheinlich
auch ein bisschen älter ist, und ältere Leute wahrscheinlich
den Film besser kennen.
Meinst du, man kriegt diese Smart-Home-Ideen im Video
auch als Personen, die wenig... Ja, kommt drauf an, welche.
Wenn Elektronik, Sensoren gebaut wird,
eigene Firmware für Microcontroller gebast wird,
dann vielleicht ein bisschen weniger.
Es gibt aber sehr viele Sachen, ich würde mal sagen,
der überwiegende Teil der Sachen kriegst du mit einfachen Mitteln hin.
Zum Beispiel, du brauchst einen Raspberry Pi
mit einem Zigbee-Stick dran,
dass du halt Wireless-Sensoren-Daten abgreifen kannst.
Dann nimmst du Temperatursensoren, Fensterkontakte und sonst was,
und damit kannst du auch schon jede Menge machen.
Fensterkontakt ist nicht nur für Fensterkontakte gut.
Das ist ja im Prinzip einfach nur ein Kontakt, der guckt,
ob was geschlossen oder offen ist.
Das kannst du für ein Hoftor benutzen, für ein Gartentor,
für ein Fenster, für ein Garagentor, für einen höhenverstellbaren
Schreibtisch, auf welcher Höhe das ist.
Da ist der Kreativität kaum Grenzen gesetzt.
Also du musst dich nicht wirklich gut damit auskennen,
wie man jetzt beispielsweise eigene Firmware für den ESP32 baut.
Und viele Sachen gibt es ja auch schon fix und fertig.
Du brauchst aber einen gewissen Hang zum Basteln.
Wenn dir das keinen Spaß macht,
dann bist du vielleicht mit irgendeiner Fertiglösung,
wenn du sowas wirklich haben willst, besser bedient.
Aber ich bin der Meinung, Fertiglösungen...
Die Smart Home-Anforderungen sind recht individuell.
Fertiglösungen ganz ohne Basteln sind meistens nicht so das.
Zumal je nach Fertiglösung du halt auch auf Gedeih und Verderben
den Herstellern ausgeliefert bist.
Jeder Furz braucht eine eigene App,
ein eigener Cloud-Server,
der Kühlschrank-Support wird nach einem Jahr eingestellt
und du kannst das Ding bloß noch als besseres Licht vorne verwenden,
den Bildschirm und sowas.
Also man braucht schon ein bisschen Spaß und Interesse am Basteln.
Und du wirst lachen, du lernst auch enorm viel.
Ich habe durch die ganze Smart Home-Geschichte,
ich habe vorher nie was mit Microcontroller-Programmieren am Hut gehabt,
nie was mit Elektronik-Basteln am Hut gehabt.
Und durch diese ganze Smart Home-Bastelei
habe ich in dem Bereich enorm viel gelernt.
Also ich kann heute simple Schaltungen auf so einem Brett stecken,
ohne dass sich dann beim Einschalten das kaputt geht und sowas.
Also die basic Sachen mit Dinger zusammenlöten,
LEDs dran, irgendwelche Schalter dran,
einen Widerstand rein, einen Kondensator.
Das kann ich heute mittlerweile ganz brauchbar.
Hatte ich vor ein paar Jahren noch überhaupt keine Ahnung von.
Also einen gewissen Hang zum Basteln braucht man schon.
Und wenn das einem Spaß macht, ist das auch ein super Hobby.
Okay, Moven und das rein.
Kannst du darauf reagieren?
Wieso haben wir doch gerade schon kurz reingeguckt da?
Oh, Hi-Res-Cack-W, oder?
Warum ist das so hochaufgelöstes Cack-W?
Hat ein AI-Generator das Cack-W?
Noch ist es ein bisschen früh für Weihnachten.
AI-Upscaler, ja.
Das könnte durchaus sein, dass das AI-Upscaled ist.
Sieht ein bisschen so aus, ja.
Man könnte es Cack-W-HD nennen.
Lass mal weitergucken.
Thema aufläuft, das wir bisher, glaube ich, noch gar nicht hatten.
Und zwar Smart Home im Wohnmobil.
Wir gucken uns das mal an.
Wenn ihr auch Sachen habt aus eurem Van-Life,
dann schmeißt sie auch gerne unter zeug.cool-zeigen in den virtuellen Briefkasten.
Und ich verwurste sie vielleicht in einer der zukünftigen Ausgaben.
Ich möchte euch heute zeigen, dass es Smart Home nicht nur zu Hause gibt,
sondern mitunter auch im Wohnmobil.
Ich habe hier den Pössl ein bisschen aufgerüstet.
Erst einmal 9% Batterieladung.
Man konnte es nicht aufladen vorher.
Und ich zeige euch einfach mal, was das ermöglicht.
Wenn ich jetzt hier mal auf Trittstufe ausfahren drücke,
fährt die Trittstufe aus.
Genau.
Das ging enorm schnell.
Je nachdem.
Trittstufe ausfahren.
Das ging ziemlich schnell.
Low-Latency-Smart Home, Leute.
Fährt die Trittstufe aus.
Genau das gleiche.
Trittstufe einfahren.
Guck mal, das waren 200, 300 Millisekunden.
Das ist enorm schnell.
Fährt die Trittstufe wieder ein.
Ich glaube, die einfahren.
Wir haben aber natürlich noch viel, viel mehr Möglichkeiten.
Man sieht es jetzt hier.
Wir haben jetzt technisch ein bisschen was eingebaut.
Beispielsweise die Deckenleuchte können wir einfach ausschalten.
Ist Fake oder hat eine Fernbedienung in der 2. Hand?
Das wäre es jetzt.
Ich meine, möglich wäre es.
Aber ich glaube ihm einfach mal, dass es funktioniert.
Und auch wieder einschalten.
Hat Handy und Fernbedienung in der 2. Hand zum Filmen.
Übers komplette Auto verteilt.
Alles mit 12 Volt wohlgemerkt.
Wir haben jetzt hier auch die Möglichkeit,
natürlich im Schlafzimmer Glaslicht auszuschalten.
Guck mal, das geht sehr, sehr zackig.
Wieder einzuschalten.
Das Ganze geht nicht nur mit dem Tablet,
sondern auch mit der Alexa.
Es ist zu spät, euch darauf hinzuweisen,
vielleicht eure smarten Assistenten stumm zu schalten.
Eben hat auch schon jemand Siri getriggert.
Naja, ihr müsst, ihr werdet es schon merken.
Das Licht im Schlafzimmer aus.
Alexa, Licht im Badezimmer aus.
Es tut mir sehr leid für eure Partner,
die jetzt im Dunkeln sitzen.
Es geht aber noch weiter.
Wir haben jetzt auch noch die Möglichkeit,
natürlich sämtliche Verbraucher, die wir so haben,
da auch noch mit anzuschließen.
Ein Wechselrichter oder was auch immer man halt so hat.
Ja, ganz schön schnell für 2017. Stimmt schon.
Hier unten sehen wir jetzt noch
Kühlschranktemperatur? Grad.
Das ist so, der Kühlschrank ist gerade ausgeschaltet.
Da sind noch Thermometer verbaut.
Einmal die Außentemperatur.
Das ist ein altes iPad, oder, was er hier hat?
Oder? Oder was ist das?
Und einmal die Kühlschranktemperatur.
Jetzt kann man das Ganze natürlich auch noch so programmieren,
dass wenn die Außentemperatur ansteigt,
beispielsweise bei keinem Kompressor-Kühlschrank,
sondern bei einem Absorber.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Kein Kompressor-Kühlschrank, sondern ein Absorber.
Merkt euch das.
Das zeigt im Kühlschrank,
dass da zum Beispiel noch ein Lüfter mit angeht oder so.
Also das sind unendliche Möglichkeiten,
die man mit Smart Home hat.
Interessant, was dein Smart Home alles macht.
Also alles außer das Aufladen des iPads.
Das habe ich auch gedacht.
Natürlich auch interessant,
wenn wir natürlich auch ein Smart Home im Urlaub nutzen wollen.
Das habe ich damals ja auch schon
in dieser Ferienwohnung ausprobiert.
Jetzt ist das Video schon ein bisschen älter.
Und ich kenne euch ja,
irgendjemand wird im Camper Van
noch ein bisschen mehr eskaliert sein.
Und ich freue mich, von dir zu hören.
So, dann hat Erich eine Automation geschickt,
die barisch...
Ich habe ja auch schon mal AI Upscaler benutzt.
Das ist das, wofür ich das erste Mal
einen AI Upscaler benutzt habe.
Für...
das Hintergrundbild hier.
Also das ist jetzt das,
was der Rackman da gebaut hat.
Aber das Windows XP-Ding Upscalen
und das Pepo-Bild im Hintergrund,
das habe ich AI Upscaled.
Sparen heißt...
Und die gucken wir uns jetzt einfach an.
Weil bares Sparen ist immer eine gute Idee.
Ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz,
wie ich bares Geld spare.
Indem ich mir eine relativ simple Automation gebaut habe,
die da sagt, wenn Apple CarPlay aktiviert wird,
das mache ich mal ganz kurz.
Please die Kamera nicht noch näher kippen.
Wer weiß, ob er noch Hose anhat.
Passiert Folgendes.
Genau.
Apple CarPlay wird aktiviert.
Passiert Folgendes.
Und zwar wird die Displayhelligkeit
auf 20% runtergelegt.
Ich habe gerne das Display an,
während der Autofahrt.
Das Display ist 20% geregelt.
Meine mobilen Daten werden aktiviert.
Und das Allerwichtigste ist,
die Blitzer-App öffnet sich
und bleibt aktiv an und auch im Hintergrund.
Du aktivierst und deaktivierst
deine mobilen Daten.
Das heißt, zu Hause sind die immer aus?
Arbeitest du mit einem Prepaid-Handy
in so einem Auto?
Naja, gut, anderer Lebensentwurf.
Ich kann die Automation mal ganz kurz keilen.
Ich glaube, Blitzer-Apps sind nicht verboten.
Blitzer-Apps sind nur dann verboten,
wenn sie Blitzer-Warnungen,
wie heißt das,
Notifications für Blitzer,
also wenn sie Warnungen aussprechen
vor Blitzern,
dann sind sie, glaube ich, verboten.
Ich glaube, eine Blitzer-App haben darfst du.
Du darfst aber keine Blitzer-App haben,
die sagt, Achtung, in 500 Metern ein Blitzer.
Einfache Automation.
Wenn Apple CarPlay verbunden wird,
dann passiert Folgendes.
Mobile Daten an,
Lautstärke 70%.
Damit ich auf Nummer sicher bin.
Blitzer-App.
Aber der typische Fall ist da wieder,
wo es keiner sieht,
passiert auch nichts.
Lichtkeit auf Stufe 20.
Okay, interessant.
Aber was spricht dagegen,
die App wieder zu beenden,
wenn CarPlay weg ist?
CarPlay weg ist doch auch ein Trigger, oder?
Wo ist denn mein Handy?
Ja, gut, aber du kannst keine Apps beenden.
Ja, vergiss es.
Irgendwas ist immer.
Es gibt keine App,
um legale Apps zu starten,
die man als Fahrer so starten kann.
Es ist mal wieder Zeit für einen Hühnerstall,
um das Tiere in dem Titel dieser Videoserie zu erfüllen.
Und zwar hat Gerrit uns
seinen automatischen Hühnerkäfig geschickt.
Da schauen wir doch mal rein,
was der so kann.
Und zwar geht es im Wesentlichen um die Klappe,
die Lüfter und den Tränkenwärmer.
Die Hühner sehen irgendwie komisch aus, oder?
Die haben so einen runden Kopf irgendwie.
Die Lüfter und den Tränkenwärmer.
Automatisierte Hühnerklappen gibt es wie Sand am Meer.
Ich habe mich aber dazu entschieden,
das gesamte System komplett selbst zu gestalten,
von der Hard- bis zur Software.
Für mich war die Integration und Home Assistant essenziell,
deshalb läuft der Code der Steuerung auf einem ESP,
der via Intuitive Home System kommuniziert.
Ja, sehr gute Idee.
Okay.
Die Klappe wird durch einen Linear-Aktuator bewegt.
Die Positionserfassung geschieht mittels Magnet
und einer jeweiligen Entlage.
Leute, das ist das, was ich meine.
Für solche kleinen Projekte lohnt es sich extrem,
weil man sich ein bisschen beschäftigt hat
mit Firmware-Programmierung
und wie so ein ESP32 funktioniert,
was du anschließen kannst.
Dafür ist der richtig super.
So kleinen Kram kriegst du super nice integriert.
Funktioniert stabil, verschickt Meldungen über MQTT
und Home Assistant, ist richtig gut.
Rätkontakte.
Sowohl die beiden Lüfter für die Zu- als auch für die Abluft
werden über einen Shelly gesteuert.
Genauso wie der Tränkenwärmer.
Der Tränkenwärmer wird aktiviert,
sobald die Außentemperatur am Hühnerstall
für mindestens 15 Minuten unter 0°C ist.
So ein Ding muss ich manchmal bei unserem Nachbar
in das Hühnergehege stellen, wenn die im Urlaub sind.
Da fragen die immer,
ob ich ab und zu den Hühnern was zu trinken bringen kann.
So ein Ding wird dann da.
Ups, hingestellt.
Und die Hühner, die sind teilweise ganz merkwürdig drauf.
Sobald du da reingehst,
manchmal stürmen sie dich richtig und denken,
du bringst ihnen was zu essen oder zu trinken.
Und manchmal sind sie übelst aufgescheucht,
wenn du da reingehst und machen 5 Minuten Krach.
Aber irgendwie fahren meine Nachbarn noch selten in Urlaub.
Also schon eine Weile her, wo ich das gemacht habe.
Wenn mindestens 15 Minuten lang 2°C gemessen wurden.
Die Lüfter werden aktiviert,
sobald der Lüfter geöffnet ist.
Und deaktiviert,
sobald der Sonnenstand in Home Assistant
auf unter dem Horizont ist.
So wird für jede Jahreszeit dafür gesorgt,
dass der maximale Luftaustausch möglich ist
und dass die Hühnchen nachts ihre Ruhe haben.
Für die Hardware habe ich meine Platine
designt und anfertigen lassen.
Das ist heutzutage recht kostengünstig.
Cool.
Da gibt es viele Anbieter, die das machen.
Aber das ist schon wirklich die Advanced Variante,
sich so ein eigenes Board bauen zu lassen.
Ich habe mich auch deshalb für ein komplettes Eigendesign entschieden.
Man muss sagen, also
für die paar Anschlüsse ist es vielleicht
fast schon Overkill.
Die Defekten habe ich alle Ersatzteile mehrfach zu Hause
und kann innerhalb kürzester Zeit
wieder ein funktionierendes System aufbauen.
In dem Schaltstrom außen am Hühnerstall
ist das System montiert.
Das sieht tatsächlich doch echt ordentlich aus.
Sogar mit Aderendhülsen drauf.
Das ist schon deutlich zu ordentlich für mich.
Rechts unten ist der Motortreiber,
der den Linearaktuator bewegt
und oben ist die bestückte Platine mit dem ESP.
Zuletzt noch die visuelle Darstellung
in Home Assistant und die Steuerungsmöglichkeiten.
Dafür gibt es vier Hauptkarten.
Die Hühner, guck mal her.
Emma, Cleo,
Sarah, kann ich nicht lesen,
Mokka, Tiffy, HiHi und Bella.
Der hat eine gute Beziehung zu seinen Hühnern.
Ein Zähler?
Wie funktioniert das?
Die Temperatur und Luftfeuchtesensoren
in und um den Stall
und zuletzt die Karte,
mit der ich auch manuell alles steuern kann.
Beim langen Drücken auf die Karte
wird die Klappe geflogen.
Wie zählst du die Eier der Hühner?
Ist das ein manueller Prozess?
Sind die so offensichtlich unterscheidbar?
Jede Aktion muss nummerquittiert werden
um ein versehentliches Schließen
demnächst x per minute ausrechnen
beziehungsweise öffnen zu verhindern.
Hier ist nochmal der Magnet am Schaftende zu sehen
und die Riedkontakte,
die die Endlage bestimmen.
Beim Erreichen der Endlage
bekomme ich dann eine Push-Nachricht auf mein Handy.
Da mir Redundanz wichtig ist,
habe ich für die Klappe und die Lüfter
trotzdem noch eine Schalter eingebaut
um bei Ausfall von Home Assistant
oder defekten Mikrocontroller
trotzdem noch Kontrolle über das System zu haben.
Warum die Klappe an einem Drahtseil hängt
und nicht direkt mit dem Linearantrieb verbunden ist,
hat mit der Sicherheit zu tun.
Ich denke einfach,
dass die Hühner nicht eingeklemmt wären.
Die Lüfter können durch ein Doppelklick
auf die Karte getriggert werden.
Auch hier muss nochmal quittiert werden.
Die Abzweigdose neben dem Antrieb
ist nicht der Hell 9000,
sondern der Schalter für das manuelle Triggern der Lüfter.
Hier drin befindet sich auch der Handy für die Steuerung.
Das ganze läuft seit knapp zwei Jahren
ohne jegliche Probleme.
Er hat sogar hier ordentlich
so einen Button mit Durchführung
und Gumminoppen so genommen.
Das hat er gut gemacht.
Er hat sogar hier ordentlich
so einen Button mit Durchführung
und Gumminoppen so genommen.
Das ganze läuft seit knapp zwei Jahren
ohne jegliche Probleme.
Ich habe letzten Endes auch immer noch die visuelle Kontrolle,
da meine Hühner große Big Brother Fans sind
und deshalb gerne freiwillig
in meiner persönlichen Staffel mitspielen.
Und ich bin ein großer Fan von Open Source.
Falls also Interesse an dem Code
bzw. weiteren Details besteht,
auch die Optik der Karten von Home Assistant
das ist alles frei zur Verfügung auf GitHub.
Aber echt gut gemacht.
Richtig gut gemacht.
Besser, besser als du dir es wahrscheinlich kaufen könntest.
Interessant.
So, wir haben sogar heute zweimal Tiere dabei.
Leon hat noch einen smarten Katzenfutterautomat.
Hallo Andreas.
Hallo Community.
Heute zeige ich euch meinen smarten Katzenfutterautomat,
welcher mit ESP Home geflasht wird.
Guck mal.
Hat ein bisschen die Farbe von
die andere Augenfarbe,
die halt grüne, meine hatte gelbe.
Vielleicht wurde auch mit
Home Assistant gesteuert wird.
Der Flash-Vorgang gestaltet sich ziemlich einfach.
Einfach ein Kabel
sowie GND und VCC anlöten
und diese mittels eines USB
zu TTL Converters am PC anschließen.
Gut, wenn das deine Definition von
wir updaten mal einfach die Firmware ist,
dann muss natürlich jeder von euch entscheiden,
ob das auch eure Definition von...
Jetzt muss der ESP nur noch geflasht werden.
Mein OTA-Update wäre natürlich deutlich nicer,
aber wie oft muss man das wahrscheinlich auch nicht updaten.
...mit dem ESP Home Webflasher.
Ein Teil des ESP Home Codes habe ich auf Reddit gefunden.
Von dieser Basis aus habe ich meine eigene Version geschrieben.
Auf Reddit?
Ok Google, füttere die Katzen.
Ah, gefällt mir.
Wenn in Home Assistant der Home-Status
auf Urlaub gesetzt wird...
Das finde ich mega...
Brauche ich sowas auch?
Wie heißt dieses Ding?
Fresh Element.
Brauche ich sowas auch?
Fresh Element Solo.
Headkit.
Das ist sogar relativ günstig.
Ich glaube, sowas brauche ich auch.
Gibt es wieder in der EU nicht zu kaufen.
Elektrohalsbander.de
Irgendwie klingt der Name dieses Shops
nicht so vertrauenserweckend, oder?
Elektrohalsbander.
Aber anscheinend...
Ok, sieht doch recht legit aus.
Impressum checken.
Impressum? Hat kein Impressum?
Ok, Direktanzeige. Abmahnung.
Auf geht's. Let's go.
Aber hat sogar auch einen YouTube Channel.
Wo ist Kontakt?
Na gut.
90 Euro.
Also, ich finde die Idee wirklich nice.
Das könnte was für Chico sein.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Habe ich mir mal überlegt.
Aber ich dachte auch,
das muss explizit als Impressum dastehen.
Amazon gibt es nichts.
Aber ich finde es eine coole Sache.
Das überlege ich mir mal.
Ich muss mir das mal kurz speichern.
Hier am zweiten Bildschirm.
So eine Notes.
Coole Sache.
Wenn in Home Assistant
der Home-Status auf Urlaub gesetzt wird,
wird die Fütterung entsprechend
eines Kalenders vollautomatisch gefüttert.
Aktuell ist das dreimal pro Tag
um 6 Uhr, um 12 Uhr und um 18 Uhr.
Falls eine automatische Fütterung durchgeführt wird
und der Futterautomat nicht antwortet,
sei es durch einen Netzwerkfehler
oder durch ein defektes Netzteil,
wird mir dies automatisch mitgeteilt.
Ich habe dann die Möglichkeit,
das Füttern nochmals zu probieren
oder die nicht wegwischbare Nachricht zu bestätigen.
Sollte bei einer Fütterung
mal das Futter ausgegangen sein,
wird mir dies ebenso mitgeteilt.
Eigentlich eine ganz simple Konstruktion.
Na gut, ergibt Sinn.
Gefällt mir, aber gut.
Gut, das ist auch kein Leben oder Tod,
wenn eine Mahlzeit für die Katzen ausfällt.
Aber wenn man im Urlaub ist,
dann haben wir ja noch mehr Code
unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Ich finde es gut.
Brauchen tut man das nicht.
Brauchen tut man das nicht,
aber ich finde es eine coole Sache.
Brauchen tust du eh das wenigste.
Verwalten habt mit eurem Home Assistant
Schaut gerne mal vorbei.
So, Thomas hat seine smarte Klimaanlagensteuerung
für eine Mitsubishi-Klimaanlage,
wie ich sie hier auch habe, geschickt.
Ich habe auch eine Mitsubishi.
Moin, Andreas.
Hey, wir sind echt ähnlich.
Ich würde dir und deinem Kanal gerne zeigen,
wie ich meine Klimaanlage von Mitsubishi
in meinen Smart Home eingebe.
Frage ist, Mitsubishi Heavy
oder Mitsubishi Electric?
Lustigerweise zwei komplett unterschiedliche Firmen,
die Klimaanlagen herstellen und beide Mitsubishi heißen.
Die Anlage wird primär mit dabei...
Mitsubishi Electric, okay.
...ebenso bietet Mitsubishi einem die Möglichkeit,
die Modelle mit einem WLAN-Modul nachzurüsten,
wenn dies nicht sogar direkt im Lieferumfang installiert war,
wie bei meinem.
Allerdings hatte ich die Reaster-App von Mitsubishi
als unglaublich unterirdisch empfunden
und bin auch kein Fan von vielen Cloud-Abhängigkeiten.
Schon gar nicht.
Wir haben im Stream auch mal eine kleine Steuerung gebaut
für meine Klimaanlage mit einem ESP2...
Nee, das war noch ein ESP2866
und Infrarot-LED konnte man quasi das machen,
was man auch über die Fernbedienung macht.
Gibt sogar eine fertige Library dafür.
Auf GitHub.
Hat ganz gut funktioniert.
Habe ich nicht mehr in Betrieb,
weil ich eigentlich die Klimaanlage
gar nicht verstelle großartig,
sondern nur ein- und ausschalte.
Und das kann ich auch mit einem Druck
auf die Fernbedienung machen.
Ich habe es mal eine Zeit lang benutzt,
als ich noch viel nach Frankfurt gefahren bin.
Da habe ich abgeglichen,
wenn ich auf dem Heimweg bin, im Zug
und meine geschätzte Ankunftszeit
kleiner 15 Minuten ist,
dann ist die Klimaanlage schon mal angegangen.
Aber nachdem ich quasi eben nur noch
4 Tage Woche plus hauptsächlich Homeoffice
und nur noch einen Modus für die Klimaanlage,
dann schalte ich einfach, wenn ich reinkomme,
das Ding mit Fernbedienung ein und in 2 Minuten ist kühl.
Ohne Kontrolle über die Daten.
Ich habe somit das WLAN-Modul
durch einen ESP32 ersetzt,
auf dem ein Open-Source-Projekt
zur Ansteuerung der seriellen Schnittstelle läuft.
Oh.
Hier musste ich lediglich
den passenden Kabelanschluss
für die Platine der Klimaanlage...
Wenn es das gibt, würde ich das auch machen.
Das ist ja cool.
Gibt es da irgendwelche Links dazu?
Ähm...
Nee.
GitHub?
Da gibt es doch bestimmt irgendeine...
ESP Home Climate for Mitsubishi Heat Pump
using direct serial connection.
Ja, das wird das sein, oder?
Wirelessly control your Mitsubishi Comfort...
...supported...
...micro-supported Mitsubishi...
Ich habe einen CN105,
der relativ sicher...
...interesting.
Ganz klares Highlight ist,
dass die Steuerung der Klimaanlage
jetzt direkt in meinem HomeKit funktioniert
und keinerlei Abhängigkeiten zum Internet besitzt.
In der Home-App lassen sich die...
Ich glaube, das müsste ich auch mal machen.
...Apps wie zum Beispiel HomePlus,
da Apple bekannterweise ja immer noch nicht
alles des HomeKit-Protokolls
in der eigenen App implementiert hat.
Mit 10 für Modus, Zieltemperatur
und Lamellenpositionen ist das eine sehr feine Sache.
Ja.
Das muss ich mir angucken.
Das ist natürlich die wahrscheinlich etwas günstigere,
aber auch etwas technisch aufwendigere Version
von dem, was ich gemacht habe,
um meine Klimaanlage mit HomeKit zu steuern.
Ich habe einfach das Taro-Modul davor geschaltet,
was die Fernbedienung quasi ersetzt.
Habe ich auch ein Video dazu gemacht,
findest du hier.
Kann man auch machen.
Aber die Lösung finde ich viel cooler.
Lokaler und günstiger.
Joachim hat Smart-Excel geschickt.
Und irgendwie schöner integriert.
What the fuck bin ich hier sehend?
Mit einem Smartphone, einer Sprachsteuerung
oder sogar mit einem Schalter ein- und auszuschalten
ist ungefähr so cool,
wie mit diesem Ding hier zu telefonieren.
Hier sieht ja jeder aus seinem Rechner
auf Excel laufen.
Was kommt denn jetzt?
Das ist die berühmte Zelle AD42.
Ach die.
Wenn man in dieser Zelle die Farbe einstellt,
dann ändert sich auch automatisch
die Farbe der Schreibtischlampe.
But why?
Cool ist es ja.
Warum?
Und das Ganze ohne irgendwelche Schalter
oder Apps oder sonstigen Kram.
Warum?
Like magic.
Okay, im Hintergrund.
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen,
wie es funktioniert.
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schwer sein.
Aber warum?
Es läuft ein kleines Python-Programm,
was abpasst, wenn die Datei sich ändert
und dann die Farbe einstellt.
Aber das ist allemal noch einfacher
als so ein blöder Lichtschalter.
Naja, wie kann man jetzt drüber streiten?
Python, ich könnte da mögen.
Man kann das Ganze natürlich auch
mit einem kleinen VBA-Skript umsetzen.
Nee, VBA wäre noch grausamer.
Ich mache Lampen,
die gleich aussehen wie eine Excel-Tabelle.
Fuck!
Was ist mit ihm los, man?
Dann muss ich einfach eine 3x8-Matrix
und dann muss ich einfach nur in Excel
die Farben eintragen,
die ich gerne dann auf der Leuchte sehen würde.
Alter!
Dann passiert ein bisschen Excel-Magie.
Smart Home-Steuerung mit Excel.
Jetzt habe ich auch alles gesehen.
Der Makro läuft.
Generiert eine Rule in OpenHub
und einen entsprechenden Schalter.
OpenHub, oh ja, war schön.
Dann füge ich in das Feld AD42
den richtigen Wert ein.
Natürlich, es muss AD42 sein.
Dann geht wie von alleine die Lampe an.
Fantastisch.
Wir können uns den ganzen Käse hier sparen.
Wir sollten einfach viel mehr Dinge
in Excel machen.
Ich glaube,
Tabellenkalkulation als Smart Home-Steuerung
ist absolut unterschätzt.
Jetzt habe ich alles gesehen.
Vielen Dank auf jeden Fall
allen Einsendern.
Wenn du auch eine Automation zu Hause hast
und du auch ein bisschen
dein Taschengeld aufbessern willst,
wirf sie mir in den virtuellen Briefkasten
und vielleicht bist du schon bei einer
der nächsten Ausgaben dabei.
Coole Sache.
Ich würde es nie so verwenden,
ehrlich gesagt.
Aber cool ist es trotzdem.
Cool ist es trotzdem.
Was haben wir denn hier jetzt noch?
We hacked Apple's Find My Network.
Okay, Chat-Gear.
Ich muss mal kurz...
Sekunde.
Ich muss mal kurz abklo.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Fünf Minuten.
Ich bin weg.
So.
Dann wollen wir mal...
Jetzt wollen die Leute schon wirklich
timeoutet werden. Na ja, auf geht's.
Okay, ah hier.
Gutes Hintergrundbildschirmer am Start.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Bald ist es soweit.
Lolman, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Du bist schon so lange dabei,
seit zehn Monaten.
Und ich habe so wenig
Messages bisher gelesen.
Du hast erst 30 Sachen im Chat geschrieben.
Wahnsinn.
Dankeschön für zehn Monate Subscription.
Du bist eher ein stiller
Enjoyer, wie es aussieht.
So, was wollte ich angucken?
Das hier. Let's go.
Ja, der Hintergrund ist ja
Bolognese und Lachs in einem quasi
so ein bisschen.
Dieses Video ist keine
Hacking-Anleitung. Es zeigt ein
mögliches... Ja, das muss er sagen,
das muss er sagen, weil YouTube sonst
im Zweifelsfall löscht, weil die Leute
bei YouTube nicht mehr durchblicken.
...Szenario, wie Hacker Apples
Wo-ist-Netzwerk nutzen könnten und wie
man sich dagegen schützen kann.
Ein Nachmachen des Angriffs ist mit
den Informationen in diesem Video und
das nochmal auf einer Tastatur.
Die hängt über USB an einem Notebook,
das, Achtung, nicht mit dem Internet
verbunden ist. Und trotzdem wird das,
was ich tippe, ins Netz übertragen.
Theoretisch mitlesbar von Angreifern,
die mir die Tastatur untergejubelt
haben. Und halt auch die Passwörter,
die ich eintippe. Verborgen in der
Tastatur ist nämlich ein sogenannter
Keylogger, der alles Getippte über
Apples Wo-ist-Netzwerk ins Internet
schickt. Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt,
das Wo-ist-Netzwerk ist doch dafür
da irgendwelche Sachen zu finden.
Dann könnt ihr auch so etwas
verwenden, wie Apple es nicht
vorgesehen hat. Nämlich um beliebige
Daten zu verschicken. Einfach über
fremde Apple-Geräte. Also wenn ihr
mit einem iPhone in der Tasche an
dieser manipulierten Tastatur
vorbeiläuft, werden die Daten über
euer iPhone übertragen, ohne dass
ihr das mitbekommt. Wie das alles
funktioniert, zeigt mir gleich der
IT-Sicherheitsexperte Ronald
Eisenberg. Bleibt dran.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von
Intel vPro. Wenn ihr Rechner für
dieses Video wollt, dann klickt
hier. Nein. Aber wenn ich die
Videos gerne gucke, Intel vPro.
Ja, schöner Service Ronald. Wir
haben ja hier das Corpus Delicti,
die böse Tastatur. Habt ihr diese
Idee, das Wo-ist-Netzwerk als
Keylogger zu benutzen? Habt ihr
das irgendwo aufgegriffen? Oder
habt ihr euch das selber ausgedacht?
Wie kam das denn zustande überhaupt?
Das Sendeverfahren ist nicht ganz
neu. Das ist im Prinzip seit
2021 bekannt. Der Fabian
Bräunlein, das ist auch der
Grund, dass man das Wo-ist-Netzwerk
benutzen kann, um beliebige Daten
zu verschicken.
Genau, da ist es zum ersten Mal
aufgefallen, weil die TU Darmstadt
angefangen hat, das Protokoll von
Wo-ist und von den AirTags
komplett auseinanderzunehmen.
Und ja, dann ist der Fabian
Bräunlein auf die Idee gekommen,
das auch zu nutzen mit einem
Trick, um beliebige Daten zu
übertragen. Er hat auch schon so
grob skizziert, dass man das zum
Beispiel für IoT-Sensoren benutzen
kann.
Eigentlich eine Mega-Idee,
oder? Du stellst irgendein
Ding an den Arsch der Welt,
irgendeinen Sensor und lässt es
über Wo bin ich?
Find my iPhone-Ding
übertragen.
Brauchst du kein LoRa,
kein sonst was?
Einfach nur?
Das ist eigentlich mega-Fivehead.
Weil es wenig Strom verbraucht
und überall verfügbar ist.
Genau, man muss dann keinen
WLAN aufbauen im Garten,
sondern man kann dann einfach das
Whois-Netzwerk verwenden.
Aber diese Idee mit dem Keylogger,
das ist tatsächlich neu.
Und wir wollten es einfach mal
wissen nach fast drei Jahren.
Am Arsch der Welt läuft keiner mit
iPhone rum, sagt es man nicht.
Funktioniert das noch?
Und wie gefährlich ist das denn
wirklich?
Dann habe ich den Fabian mal
gefragt, wie es denn aussieht.
Und er hat dann diese Tastatur
gebaut, wo der Keylogger einfach
eingebaut ist und unseren Test
auch recht zuverlässig funktioniert
hat. Wir haben im Vorfeld schon
Versuche gemacht.
Ich meine, so wild.
Das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen
konstruiert. Das Ding könnte genauso
gut über irgendein
GPS-Modul.
GPS-Modul musst du irgendwie
registrieren. Es ist schon cool.
Wenn ich mir so recht überlege,
hat doch enorme Vorteile.
Also dass wahrscheinlich mehr oder
weniger gut mit Fake-Account
halbwegs anonym benutzen kannst.
Platte E-Mail übertragen,
mit nur ganz wenigen Fehlern,
die nicht wichtig waren.
Und sowas wie Passwörter sind von
der Länge auch überhaupt kein
Problem.
Ja, Texteingaben verbrauchen
halt wenig Speicher und
sind dementsprechend auch recht
easy übertragen.
Ja, dann lass uns das doch einfach
mal ausprobieren.
Dann rufen wir doch den Fabian
Bräunlein mal an.
Der ist gerade in Hongkong.
Und dann tippen wir mal was auf der
Tastatur und gucken, ob
das bei dem ankommt.
Und wir gucken, ob das bei dir
ankommt.
Wir haben ja auch Mac-Devices auf
jeden Fall.
Die hoffentlich
sind ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Gehen denn eigentlich auch, ich
habe mich einmal vertippt,
Backspaces und so.
Wird das dann mit übertragen?
Genau, ich glaube, das habe ich
so programmiert, dass das
dann angezeigt wird als
Backspace irgendwie.
Ich glaube, Klammer, also
eckige Klammer auf,
Backspace, eckige Klammer zu oder
so ähnlich.
Also es kann halt sein, dass jetzt
quasi iPhone 1
Buchstaben 1 aufnimmt
und überträgt und ein anderes
Gerät dann den zweiten Buchstaben.
Genau. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und was sind das für?
Warum sind das sechs
unterschiedliche Textfelder, die
du hast?
Das sind jetzt die
unterschiedlichen Nachrichten
IDs.
Also Nachricht ID Nummer 0
war der
autogenerierte Text von heute
Morgen oder letzten, letzten
Freitag war das.
Genau.
Ah ja.
So jetzt sieht es doch gut aus.
Also okay.
Die Backspaces
sind so.
Das ist aber, das ist aber
nice, dass das also
nice und nicht nice zugleich.
Aber.
Für irgendwelche Sensoren ist das
ja wirklich mega cool.
Gekennzeichnet und
genau.
Nicht nicht allzu weit weg von
hier gibt es einen Bahnübergang.
Und ich habe mir schon ein paar
Mal überlegt, es wäre für Wege
wie ich wie ich renne und
so manchmal nützlich zu wissen,
bevor ich loslaufe,
ob der Bahnübergang offen oder zu
ist.
Theoretisch.
Ich meine, man darf daran nichts
machen.
Ja, man darf daran nichts machen,
aber
man könnte so ein Fenster Kontakt
Sensor irgendwie da dran.
Na gut, da müssen wir immer noch
überlegen, wie kriege ich, wie
kriege ich.
Das zurück übertragen.
Ja.
Nutzt man dann Apples Infrastruktur
kostenlos für Dinge, die nicht
dafür gedacht sind?
Ja, ja, ja.
Praktisch ist es schon.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall der
Satz.
Und die Fragezeichen bedeuten,
dass da noch.
Nein, ich klebe nichts an die
Schranke. Ich meine, aber die Idee
finde ich cool.
Ich mache das nicht, aber die Idee
finde ich gut.
Im besten Fall.
Da fehlt jetzt noch was.
Wir können auch mal einmal kurz
hier in den Konsolen
Output reinschauen.
Also das sind Klammern hier.
Klammer 1.
Das Laura Modul bringt dir halt
was, wenn du in der Nähe bist.
Bei der Schranke wäre es
definitiv in der Nähe.
Ich habe ja mit Laura mal was
gebaut, um
so ungefähr einen Kilometer zu
überbrücken.
Das ging auch ganz gut.
Aber wenn es weiter weg ist,
kommst du halt auch mit Laura
nicht gut hin.
Sei denn du bist auf dem Berg.
Hast direkte Sichtlinie.
Da ist das wirklich nice.
Also zum Beispiel.
Ich fahre ja ganz gerne mal
Richtung Spessart zum Wandern.
Mal angenommen, ich möchte wissen,
ob es dort regnet.
Ich weiß, das kriegt man einfach
heraus. Ja, aber nur mal ein
Beispiel.
Würde ich dort einen Regensensor
irgendwo hinlegen
und
das dann verschicken lassen?
Und da in der Nähe sind garantiert
genug iPhones.
Klammer 2.
Das bedeutet praktisch, wie viele
Pings haben wir für
dieses Byte?
Auf dem Turm.
Ja, aber
das ist, das ist
das.
Viele, viele Möglichkeiten
bietet das.
Wie oft hat ein iPhone
oder wie viele unterschiedliche
Geräte haben das inzwischen
weitergeleitet?
Und wir sehen für viele davon
haben wir erst eins.
Und wenn wir jetzt noch mal
auf Reload Message klicken.
Helium für Laura.
Ich kenne das Things Network
für Laura.
Helium für Laura.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ah, okay.
Die CT 3003.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und das nächste Wort kannst du dir
wahrscheinlich auch herleiten.
Hart.
Ja.
Aber nur 992.
Also vielmehr ist es auch nicht.
Ah, ich war doch kurz auf eurem
YouTube Channel.
Ja.
992.000
X Subscriber.
Genau.
Abonnenten.
Ja.
Was ist Laura?
Ein Funk Protokoll,
was ausgelegt ist auf möglichst
Long Range.
Also niedrige Daten
Übertragungsrate, aber lange
Reichweite.
Also was ich mit Laura schon mal
gemacht habe, ist über einen
Kilometer paar Bytes
übertragen.
Das ist wirklich.
Es ist.
Leute, das könnt ihr absolut nicht
mit WLAN vergleichen.
Bei WLAN reden wir ja von
teilweise mittlerweile Gigabytes
pro Sekunde oder zumindest mal
Megabytes, Megabits
pro Sekunde.
Gigabits, nicht Gigabytes.
Gigabits pro Sekunde, wenigstens
Megabits pro Sekunde.
Bei Laura reden wir von.
Ungefähr.
Ja.
Zwei Byte.
Zwei Byte pro
acht Sekunden, so wie ich das
gemacht habe.
Das kam aber halt dementsprechend
auch sehr sicher an.
Laura kommt richtig weit mit Sicht
Kontakt, aber ich habe halt nicht
unbedingt Sicht Kontakt.
Immer.
Es gibt ja sogar Satelliten mit
Laura, wo man funken kann.
Also ich habe, ich habe
Sensordaten übertragen.
Das war nur ein paar Byte.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, Testweise
wirklich nur zwei Byte übertragen.
Und das hatte ein Sendefenster
so von 80 oder von fünf Sekunden
oder so.
Also könnt ihr euch, könnt ihr euch
überlegen, so zwei Byte, fünf
Sekunden.
Nee, nicht so lange.
Hat sich genau zwei Sekunden
vielleicht.
Ist schon echt lahm.
Ja, aber für einfache, simple
Werte reicht es halt dicke aus.
Und dafür geht es halt weit.
Ja, aber ich meine, ich würde
sagen, das reicht uns ja noch
schon.
Hast du eine Erklärung dafür,
warum Apple das so?
20 Kilometer kriegst du gut hin,
wenn du halt Sichtweite hast.
Mit Sichtweit, also mit Sicht, mit
Sichtkontakt kriegst du auch viel
größere hin.
Aber hast du halt in der Stadt
oftmals nicht.
Also ich, ich habe Beispiel, ich
habe bei mir,
ich habe bei mir hier auf den
Schrank, habe ich die Lora
Antenne gelegt und
bin dann auf,
ja hier auf den Friedhof gelaufen
und also in die Richtung
und habe ein bisschen über den
Kilometer so
dann, dann gefunkt von dort und
zurück, dass das ging.
Wenn man, wenn man Lora
flächendeckend benutzen will, dann
kann man sowas wie TTN verwenden,
braucht man halt an der Stelle
Coverage, wo man
wo man gerade ist.
Also TTN ist ein Lora
Netzwerk, was
ja so ein, wo man sich anmelden
kann und
dann quasi die Leute ihre Lora
Antennen zur Verfügung stellen,
allen möglichen verschlüsselnden
Traffic zu empfangen und die
dann über das Internet zum Ziel
zu leiten.
Also dann reicht es, wenn du
irgendein Lora Gerät in der Nähe
hast.
TTN Map.
Also mal angenommen, ihr wollt,
ihr seht ja, also Coverage ist
eigentlich ganz gut, aber
angenommen, ihr wollt, ihr
kannst ja nichts drauf erkennen.
Können wir irgendwie suchen oder
so?
Ich würde gerne Frankfurt suchen,
das ist zu viel, ich erkenne
nichts.
Way too dank, Alter.
Wo sind wir hier überhaupt?
Konnte man hier nicht mal nach
Städten und so suchen?
Hatte doch mal eine Möglichkeit.
Hä?
Kacke gemacht.
Gehen wir mal hier nach
Frankfurt.
Mal angenommen, ich will am
Hauptbahnhof einen Sensor
anbringen.
Seht ihr?
In Frankfurt habe ich noch ganz
gute Chancen, da Zugang zu
finden.
Okay, keine Ahnung, die Map ist
übelst für den Arsch.
Verzögert oft?
Ja, ich könnte euch theoretisch da
eigentlich auch Daten liefern
anhand von einer ziemlich großen
Datenmenge, wie lange praktisch
immer die Latenz ist.
Und es gibt auf jeden Fall
Situationen, wo iPhones das
innerhalb der ersten Minute
praktisch weiterleiten, die
Location.
Aber eben teilweise auch bis zu
einer Stunde, bis zu einer Stunde
Verzögerung.
Und ich glaube, der Hauptgrund
ist, ja,
Akku, die Akkulaufzeit zu
erhöhen und Batterie zu sparen.
Moin, hier ist Schein aus dem
Schnitt, da das Übertragen der
Nachricht noch eine Weile gedauert
hat, hat uns Fabian dann ein paar
Stunden später noch das
Endergebnis geschickt.
Hier fehlt nur noch das O, aber
ansonsten ist alles angekommen,
inklusive der Vertepper von Kino.
Eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Du siehst jetzt ganz kurz nochmal die
vereinfachte technische Erklärung,
wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Der Keylogger in der manipulierten
Tastatur sendet über Bluetooth
permanent Signale aus, die Apple
Geräte, also iPhones, iPads oder
MacBooks in der Nähe auffangen und
an Apple schicken.
Eigentlich ist das Ganze zum
Finden von Dingen gedacht.
Wir haben ja neulich erst ein
Video gemacht, wie ich meinen mit
einem AirTag versehenes Fahrrad im
Wald wiedergefunden habe.
Man kann das zugrundeliegende Wo
ist Netzwerk aber eben auch so
verwenden, wie es nicht von Apple
vorgesehen ist, nämlich um beliebige
Daten zu verschicken, wie alle
Tastendrücke unserer manipulierten
Tastatur.
Standardmäßig sind alle aktuellen
Apple Geräte so eingestellt, dass sie
diese Wo ist Daten auffangen und
versenden.
Man kann das aber manuell
deaktivieren.
Unter iOS zum Beispiel auf
Einstellungen auf den eigenen Namen
gehen.
Ja gut.
Mein iPhone suchen und da dann Wo
ist Netzwerk.
Da kann man es aber selbst sicher
verwenden.
Wenn ihr Details dazu wissen wollt,
ich habe euch den CT-Artikel dazu in
der Beschreibung verlinkt.
Sag nochmal einmal ganz kurz, was
ist da jetzt drin?
Also wir haben jetzt gesagt, wir
benutzen das Wo ist Netzwerk.
Was ist da jetzt genau drin?
Und was macht diese Tastatur jetzt
genau?
Die Tastatur ist mit einem Keylogger
ausgestattet.
Das ist so ein kleines Modul.
Was mich viel mehr interessiert, ist
wie man das verwenden kann.
Ob es dort fertige irgendwelche
ESP 32 Bluetooth
Libraries gibt.
Das wäre ja mega.
Da könnte man irgendwo so ein Ding
hinstellen und
ab und zu mal was schicken lassen.
Wobei ein ESP 32 ist in den Batterie
Betrieb halt ein bisschen painstjam.
Steckt man das zwischen USB Kabel
und Rechner, wie so ein Zwischenstecker,
fällt halt auch keinem auf.
Insbesondere wenn es hinten am Rechner
ist, da guckt man eh nicht hin.
Der Keylogger ist jetzt hier aber
eingebaut.
Also ob Apple das lange zulässt?
Anscheinend schon.
Die haben doch gesagt, das ist seit
Jahren schon bekannt.
Mit drin, da ist relativ viel Platz
drin, weil diese Tastaturelektronik.
Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, wie
Easy Apple das patchen kann,
weil sonst gehen
auf einen Schlag alle nicht
geupdateten Geräte nicht mehr zu
finden. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Apple
überhaupt Interesse daran hat.
Wie liest man das dann aus?
Ich denke mal, dass man dieses Gerät,
dieses Fake-Gerät hinzufügt
zu seinem Wo-ist-Account.
Das wird sich halt melden,
ich bin ein verlorenes
iPhone oder so, dass Apple das
durchlässt.
Das ist soweit miniaturisiert,
dass man da einfach Luft hat, um
noch einen Keylogger einzubauen.
Und der sitzt quasi jetzt
zwischen dem, was
die Tastatur macht.
Also wenn du drauf tippst, das geht
erstmal an den Keylogger und von da geht
es dann weiter an den Rechner.
Und der Keylogger hat jetzt noch
ein paar Extras. Also zum einen
das ist halt ein ESP32 drauf,
der Bluetooth und WLAN hat.
Und der nutzt das, um sich quasi
wie so ein AirTag zu verhalten und
sendet ganz viele Pakete durch die Luft.
Und die werden von
iPhones aufgefangen und an das Apple
Wo-ist-Netz weiter gereicht.
Hier bei der Tastatur würde es jetzt auch
zum Beispiel reichen, wenn einfach im
Nebenraum oder so jemand vorbeiläuft
oder sogar auf der Straße wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaube aber trotzdem für
Batteriebetrieb ist das nichts, weil
du musst doch schon in recht hoher
Frequenz senden, dass du die Chancen
erhöhst, dass ein iPhone in der Nähe
das auffängt.
Und deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich
für Sensoren,
die mit Batterie laufen,
nicht so geil.
Ja, bei der Tastatur ist klar,
aber mir geht es ja nicht um Tastatur.
Also irgendein Sensor
mit Batterie dürfte dann recht schnell
leer sein, spätestens nach
ein paar Wochen. In der Tastatur
kannst du da natürlich was von abgreifen.
AirTag hat auch nur eine Batterie.
Aber ein AirTag macht
nichts anderes wie
ähm
Bluetooth-Sachen schicken.
Bei einem Microcontroller
musst du den Microcontroller noch mit Strom
versorgen, der den Sensor ausliest
und dann diese Sache über Bluetooth schickt. Das braucht
um vielfaches mehr Strom.
AirTag hat ja keine große
äh
Firmware drauf, die da was macht.
Der schickt einfach nur
Bluetooth-Messages alle, weiß ich nicht,
5 Sekunden oder so.
Ja, also wenn du dir das überlegst, selbst wenn man Ultra-Low-Power
ESP32 nehmen würde,
gibt's doch hier was.
Gibt's doch hier so einen schönen Calculator.
IoT Live Calculator.
Was ist da? Also
Duration of Code Execution.
2 Sekunden, sagen wir mal,
ist relativ
ja, vielleicht ein bisschen langer, mal eine Sekunde.
Dann sleept er
2 Minuten, das ist ok.
Dann braucht er
in dem Moment, das sind Milliampere.
Ne.
During Code Execution, ja doch,
During Code Execution braucht er 100 Milliampere,
das ist ok.
Und ja, during sleep
braucht er, keine Ahnung, 20 Microampere.
Gibt's zum Beispiel ESP32.
Ja, der ist relativ
Low-Power
im Stand-By.
Der hat im Stand-By
braucht er nur
wird da irgendwas?
Sleep.
Irgendwie 10 Microampere oder so.
Steht natürlich mal wieder
nix da, das Wichtigste steht einfach nicht da.
Steht mal wieder nix dabei.
Also der hat nicht viel.
Ja.
10 Microampere
Deep Sleep.
Dann nehmen wir nur 2000 Milliampere Stunden.
Discharger 10%.
So.
Läuft nur 90 Tage.
Das ist echt, das zieht
Batterie, das Ding.
Man kann das
extrem steigern durch höhere Sleep Time.
Wenn ich den nur noch
alle 240 aufwache,
lasse, sieht man es schon doppelt so viel.
Aber das Ding ist halt,
die Sleep Time darf nicht so hoch sein.
Weil sonst ist die Chance
zu gering, dass es ein iPhone mitbekommt.
Eigentlich müsste es eine Sleep Time
von
20 Sekunden oder so sein.
Und dann hält es bloß 15 Tage.
Also deswegen, Batteriebetrieb von solchen Dingern ist meistens
gar nicht so easy.
Man kann natürlich auf gut Glück hoffen.
Und
dann hält es ein bisschen.
Das ist quasi einmal die Stunde
aufwachen nur.
So.
Das ist dann gut.
Realistisch betrachtet hält es mal 2-3 Jahre oder so.
Vielleicht.
Das ist dann gut.
Aber
einmal pro Stunde aufwachen und senden,
die Chance, dass da zufälligerweise
gerade ein iPhone in der Nähe ist
und das mitbekommt,
ist dann halt auch nicht so hoch.
Es reicht vor allen Dingen auch,
wenn das irgendwann passiert.
Weil die Tastatur sendet ja in so einen Loop
die ganze Zeit.
Da ist es ja auch kein Problem.
Wenn mal ein iPhone oder was Ähnliches vorbeikommt und die Daten abholt,
reicht das schon aus, um die Daten zu übertragen.
Was ist denn jetzt der Vorteil
statt WLAN,
das Wo-ist-Netzwerk zu verwenden?
Den kann man über WLAN verbinden.
Es gibt auch diverse andere Keylogger mit WLAN.
Das Problem ist immer,
du brauchst natürlich erstmal ein WLAN,
um das Gerät zu verbinden.
Und im Zweifel, wenn es jetzt ein echter
Spionageangriff wäre,
ist das natürlich auffällig,
wenn man sich ein Gerät über WLAN
mit dem vorhandenen Netz,
mit dem Firmennetz zum Beispiel, verbindet.
Das ist deutlich angenehmer.
Du brauchst auch kein GPS-Modul
oder irgendwas,
was registriert werden muss.
Das ist ziemlich easy.
Aus Angreifersicht ist das, denke ich,
eine super Übertragungsmöglichkeit.
Unternehmensnetze sind recht schnell auf.
Die Alternative wäre,
dass der Keylogger selber einen Accesspoint aufspannt.
Auch das ist sichtbar.
Es gibt aber auch andere Lösungen.
Enzyme zum Beispiel, die WLAN-Netze erkennen.
Genau, das ist das Ding.
Wenn man das über WLAN abschnorcheln würde,
dann würde das eher auffallen.
Was hat man denn für Möglichkeiten,
wenn man Angst hat,
dass man
eine Tastatur untergejubelt bekommt
oder dass irgendeiner mit dem
Wo-ist-Netzwerk schinden oder treibt?
Kann ich das sehen,
dass das Wo-ist-Netzwerk missbraucht wird,
um solche Dinge zu tun?
Als WLAN sind diese Bluetooth-Pakete
kaum sichtbar.
Die werden nicht irgendwo angezeigt,
standardmäßig.
Man kann probieren,
mit BLE-Scanner-Apps
nach diesen Paketen zu gucken.
Das klappt ganz gut mit Android
oder auch mit Windows.
Mit Apple klappt es nicht.
Ausgerechnet mit den Apple-Betriebssystemen
allerdings nicht,
weil die nicht die Absender-Megadressen
der Bluetooth-Pakete anzeigen.
Auf Android-Geräten sieht man
ein Apple-Device,
was da nicht hingehört.
Da tauchen ganz viele
Apple-Devices auf.
Man sieht, dass die
Absender-Megadressen in unserem Fall
relativ ähnlich sind.
Das hat mit dem Codierungsverfahren zu tun,
wie diese Daten
in die Pakete eingebaut werden.
Da kann man schon
ein bisschen drauf kommen,
aber man muss danach scannen.
Das ist auch nur eine Momentaufnahme,
weil die Tastatur oder andere Geräte,
wo sowas eingebaut ist,
die müssen ja jetzt gerade gar nicht senden.
Die können auch zwei, drei Tage
Daten sammeln und dann plötzlich
anfangen, die rauszusenden.
Man kann zum Beispiel
ein Android-Handy nehmen,
dann den BLE-Scanner.
Das ist eine kostenlose App.
Wenn man dann ganz viele Apple-Devices sieht,
die mit unterschiedlichen
Megadressen irgendwas machen,
die hellhörig werden.
Realistisch gesehen
hast du so ein Ding jetzt nicht einfach mal daheim stehen.
Auf einmal
so random ist in deiner Tastatur was drin.
Die wenigsten werden das
wirklich ausprobieren.
Es können natürlich auch AirTags sein.
Aber dann wahrscheinlich nicht so viele.
Ja, eher unwahrscheinlich.
Bei uns ist es noch recht gut erkennbar,
weil das Verfahren relativ
simpel ist. Es ist vorhersehbar,
dass die Megadressen sehr ähnlich sind.
Nur die letzten Ziffern ändern sich.
Ein echter Angreifer kann aber auch mit
beliebigen Absender-Megadressen arbeiten.
Da kann es sehr gut sein,
dass sie komplett unterschiedlich sind,
dass man sie nicht mit dem bloßen Auge erkennt.
Da könnte man dann wieder über die schiere Anzahl
gehen. Also wenn jetzt 20, 30
Geräte auftauchen,
plötzlich ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas im Busch.
Wobei auch da wieder
so eine
Tastatur kann eben auch
beliebig lange warten mit den einzelnen Paketen.
Es kann sein, dass es nur ein Paket
alle 10 Minuten verschickt und dann
nach zwei, drei Tagen doch das Passwort
übertragen ist.
Das macht es halt so schwierig.
Die ganzen Warnfunktionen, die es ja gibt,
Android macht das,
Wer seine Passwörter eintippt?
Wahrscheinlich ganz viele Leute.
Wenn man von einem AirTag längere Zeit
begleitet wird, der einem nicht gehört,
die springen halt nicht an.
Ja genau, das habe ich auch ausprobiert.
Ich habe mit meinem iPhone
die Woist App, da kann man
ja nach AirTags suchen,
ist da nicht aufgetaucht.
Danke Ronald, schön, dass du uns das
erklärt hast. Mein Fazit,
also ich finde das auf einer technischen
Ebene einigermaßen faszinierend,
dass das tatsächlich geht. Also das
Woist Netzwerk so zu hacken, dass man es
für andere Dinge nutzen kann, als nur
zur Positionsübertragung. Und natürlich
birgt das hier beschriebene Szenario auch
ein gewisses Gefährdungspotenzial.
Schließlich musste man für bisherige
Logger entweder die Software manipulieren,
die auf dem Rechner läuft, an denen die
Tastatur angeschlossen ist, oder man musste
eine andere Datenübertragungsmethode nutzen,
zum Beispiel WLAN. Und fremde
WLAN-Geräte... Also jetzt bin ich aber mal
gespannt. ...lassen sich einigermaßen...
Gibt es da irgendwelche fertigen...
Ups...
Find...
Find my network...
Aufgetaucht. Gibt es doch bestimmt irgendwas Fertiges.
Guck mal hier, was ist denn das?
Build your own AirTags today.
Framework for tracking personal Bluetooth devices
via Apple's massive... Siehste?
Easy zu finden, sowas.
Frage ist, ob es auf dem ESP geht
oder irgendwo.
Scheint auch recht beliebt zu sein.
7,200...
Ja, 7200 Sterne.
Firmware für was?
ESP32-Firmware!
Na, guck mal da.
Ja, siehste?
Sind wir schon dabei.
Was ist denn ein Microbit V1?
Was sind das
für Dinger?
Microbit...
Pocket-sized...
Also, gibt es wohl genug Möglichkeiten.
Sehr interessantes
Zeug.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich da einen Bastel-Stream mache.
Ich habe noch keinen genauen Anwendungszweck für.
Die Idee muss ich aber mal
im Hinterkopf behalten.
Tracking vom Auto.
Naja.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Aber da habe ich eh das iPhone dabei.
Da kann ich gucken.
Da muss ich mich auch nicht selbst tracken.
Da weiß ich ja, wo ich bin.
Ja, aber für Autotracking
könnte ich mir das gut vorstellen.
Da geht es auch mit Batterie.
Oder du schlöpselst halt innen an,
wenn es ein Auto ist, wo du selbst reinkommst.
Also...
Interessante Anwendungsmöglichkeiten.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe jetzt noch direkt nichts,
was mir so einfällt.
Wozu das...
Wozu ich das benutzen könnte.
Aber...
Ja, ich denke,
da ergibt sich vielleicht irgendwann mal was.
Fahrrad.
Mein Fahrrad hat kein Dynamo.
Wenn ich Fahrrad fahre
und meinen Weg tracken will,
habe ich mein Garmin dabei.
Also es gibt...
Ich überlege mir eher was für irgendwelche Sensoren.
Ja.
Irgendwo, wo man was abfragen möchte.
Wo man halt
recht weit weg ist.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Batterie betrieben
ist es mit LoRa auf jeden Fall sinniger.
Naja.
Weiß ich nicht. Mal gucken.
Was ist eurer Meinung nach
die beste Variante,
eine Programmiersprache zu lernen?
PowerShell. Wow.
Wie kommt es, PowerShell?
Brauchst du das für die Arbeit?
Ganz im Ernst?
Du hast es schon richtig gemacht.
Das Beste, was zu lernen,
wenn man ein bisschen die Grundlagen schon kann,
ist sich anzugucken,
wie andere Leute Sachen machen.
Und sich dann rauszuziehen,
okay, wie setzt man am besten was um?
Aber...
Wie man jetzt konkret PowerShell lernt?
Also ich kann dir keine guten Kurse oder Bücher
empfehlen. Ich habe keine Ahnung davon.
Großartig. Ich habe sehr wenig bisher
in PowerShell gemacht.
Ansonsten wahrscheinlich wie alles andere auch
sich angucken, was andere
in PowerShell programmiert haben.
Nachzuvollziehen, was die gemacht haben.
Sich da rausziehen, wie man Sachen am besten in PowerShell umsetzt.
Und sich mal ein bisschen am Anfang
die Basics angucken.
Wie macht man Schleifen?
Wie peipt man Informationen von einem
Befehl in den anderen?
Ansonsten kannst du auch mal gucken, ob es ein gutes
PowerShell Buch gibt.
Oder eben
auch noch als
Papier.
Das kenne ich gar nicht.
Aber vielleicht gibt es auch ein paar ganz gute
PowerShell Bücher.
Ich hatte mal eins, das war so orange.
Das hatte ich mal
auf der Arbeit, auf der alten Arbeit.
PowerShell Buch.
War so orange-blau.
Ne, das war es
nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Learn PowerShell.
Wow, wow, wow.
Wie lange arbeitest du so am Tag als IT-Trainer?
Mit dem Beruf in der Vollzeit
meist nur 4 Stunden pro Tag.
Ist unterschiedlich.
Aber
ich glaube, dass du
8 Stunden am Stück
100% mit dem Hirn immer
am Denken bist,
ist selten.
Ich glaube, die wenigsten
Leute schaffen das überhaupt.
8 Stunden am Stück, da 100%
fokussiert zu sein.
Wenn du 2-3 Stunden wirklich
super konzentriert bist und was machst,
kannst du den restlichen Tag
so sinnlos Sachen erledigen,
wie die erledigt werden müssen.
Du kannst auf irgendwelche Meetings hocken,
du kannst irgendwelche
Zeiterfassungssachen ausfüllen,
Tickets bearbeiten, was auch immer.
Das, wo du kein
High-IQ-Modus brauchst.
2-3 Stunden konzentriert was machen
und den restlichen Tag
Low-IQ-Arbeit.
Die haben halt das High-Performance-Mindset.
Ich geb dir mal
einen Tipp an der Stelle.
Also wenn du sagst, du musst
4 Stunden mit Youtube-Videos überprüfen,
ist nicht verkehrt, dann bringt dich
die Arbeit wenigstens nicht um und du bist schön entspannt
für dich, aber ich geb dir
trotzdem mal einen Tipp.
Versuch mal in der Zeit, dich mit neuer Technik
zu beschäftigen, die relevant ist
für die Arbeit.
Sei es jetzt
PowerShell zu lernen, falls ihr Windows-Sachen macht
oder irgendwie dein Bash-Scripting-Zeug
aufzufrischen, dich ein bisschen mit
Sachen zu beschäftigen, die vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt
sind für deinen Job und
jetzt kommt Trick 17.
Jetzt kommt Trick 17.
Wenn du 4 Stunden coole Sachen
gemacht hast,
dann verbring zumindest mal einen Teil
deiner anderen Zeit,
das noch ein bisschen
zu durchdenken und das gut
zu verkaufen, was du gemacht hast.
Also sprich,
wenn du was richtig geiles
dir überlegt hast,
ich mein, das machst du ja nicht jeden Tag,
aber wenn du dir alle 1-2 Wochen was richtig
cooles gemacht hast, dann mach dir mal ein bisschen
Gedanken drüber, wie du das am besten
der breiteren Öffentlichkeit
auf der Arbeit unter die Nase reiben
kannst, dass du was geiles gemacht hast.
Weil was geiles machen,
ohne dass es jemand mitbringt,
hast du nichts von.
Es ist besser, also mal angenommen, du könntest
in der gleichen Zeit 2
geile Sachen machen, die ganz toll sind
für deinen Arbeitgeber
versus du machst in der gleichen Zeit
eine Sache, die ganz toll ist
und redest die zweite Zeit
da drüber, ist das für
dich und deine Gehaltsentwicklung
wahrscheinlich die bessere Variante.
Also es ist immer besser,
dass wenn du was tolles gemacht hast,
da ein bisschen drüber zu labern, als die
zweite tolle Sache zu machen.
Du musst das immer ein bisschen
verkaufen können, was du gemacht hast.
Es ist auch sinnvoll, sich das aufzuschreiben
und das ab und zu mal seinem Chef
zu erzählen. Falls du irgendwie Möglichkeiten
hast, das auf irgendwelchen Abteilungsrunden
vorzustellen, ist es auch nicht verkehrt.
Ab und zu mal was Geiles machen,
aber das richtig schön breittreten.
Das bringt einen am weitesten, so plötzlich
es anhört. Ja, ich find das
auch bescheuert oftmals, ja.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich sage, ja,
das find ich super geil, aber es ist
halt so. Und gerade wenn du
irgendwie was, keine Ahnung, stell dir mal
vor, du findest raus, wie man
in eurer
Anwendung Wartezeiten irgendwie um 30%
reduzieren kann
und sowas. Was dann dafür sorgt, dass
irgendwie 15% mehr
Leute ihren Einkauf abschließen
und so. Das bringt enorm viel Kohle
für die jeweilige Firma. Wenn du das
aber einfach nur machst und nichts
dazu erzählst, dann wird das halt einfach
beim nächsten Versionsupdate zur Kenntnis
genommen oder aber gar nicht
damit in Verbindung gebracht, dass du das gewesen
bist. Das heißt, es ist wirklich
besser, wenn du da drüber dann auch noch
breit ein bisschen
das
darlegst,
wie toll du die Performance verbessert
hast der Anwendung. Da hast du
mehr davon. Das ist einfach so. So plötz
klingt,
zwei bis drei Stunden was Tolles machen,
zwei bis drei Stunden drüber reden ist besser
als sechs Stunden was Tolles machen.
Meistens ist es natürlich nicht so.
Meistens macht man ab und zu mal was wirklich Tolles.
Die meisten Sachen sind jetzt ja auch nicht wirklich
großartig der Rede wert.
Und
dann kann man das auch
ab und zu mal ordentlich breitreden.
Genau. Außerdem denken die Leute
sonst ist es selbstverständlich, dass du quasi
ganz viele tolle Sachen auf die
Reihe kriegst und beschweren sich dann noch
wenn es mal nicht
so ist. Dabei kriegt
sonst keiner was Tolles auf die Reihe. Aber
die Leute gewöhnen sich dran.
Man darf auch nicht zu viel machen.
Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr seid in einem Team,
alle schaffen, wir machen es jetzt mal ein simples
Beispiel, weil, auch wenn es nicht
realitätsnah ist,
alle schaffen 10 Tickets am Tag
und ihr schafft 20 Tickets am Tag.
Und irgendwann schafft ihr nur noch
auch 10 Tickets am Tag.
Aber es haben sich alle dran gewöhnt, dass ihr 20 Tickets am Tag
schafft. Dann kriegst du demnächst noch eine
Performanceoptimierungsmaßnahme oder
warum auf einmal deine
Leistungsfähigkeit so eingebrochen ist.
Also heißt besser, besser
nur 5 Tickets am Tag machen
und super krass
drüber erzählen, wie ultra
kompliziert und
super pfeifett die Probleme waren
und wie du dich da durchgekämpft hast
und was du alles gemacht hast und so.
Und dann sagen sie alle, boah Alter, der hat aber die
richtig krassen Probleme weggeschafft.
Anstatt einfach 20 Tickets am Tag zu machen.
Es ist einfach unterm Strich besser für dich.
Es ist so doof klingt, ja.
Für dich ist es entspannter
und es ist besser. Also gar
keine Frage, ob man das machen sollte.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Geschichte
du meinst, aber das ist überall so.
Ja, das musst du
auf jeden Fall ordentlich breittreten,
dass du das gemacht hast.
Und am besten,
also das Mindeste, was du machen musst,
ist es bei dir im Team ein bisschen erzählen, aber die haben
es wahrscheinlich schon mitgeklickt. Wichtig ist
auch, dass du es deinem Chef regelmäßig
mal erzählst und wenn es die Möglichkeit
gibt, dass du das irgendwo mal
vorstellst, ja, sei es,
dass es irgendwelche übergreifenden Runden gibt
oder so, mach das. Setz dich hin und
erzähl das denen. Machst du 20 Minuten
Präsentation darüber,
dass alle mitgekickt haben, dass du der krasse
Monitor-Fivehead bist.
Und...
Und dann
rufst du dich die nächsten paar Wochen aus, so.
Und erzählst weiter drüber.
Bis du das nächste geile Ding gemacht hast,
ich rufe das alte geile Ding immer wieder.
Ja, das stimmt. Ey, das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Ich mein,
Druckerpatronen einsetzen und irgendwie was
bisschen Fiveheadiges programmieren, ist dann nur
wirklich...
Ach so! Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, hatten wir.
Ja. Nie, hat nie
einer was von mitgekriegt, großartig.
Und, und alle dachten,
wenn der weg ist, ist es nicht schlimm, bis er irgendwann mal
weg war. Ja, ja, ja, ja, genau.
Naja, der war sozial nicht schlecht,
das war ein super netter Kerl, aber der hat einfach seine
Sachen nie an die große Glocke gehängt.
Bis er irgendwann weg war, und wir wussten
das natürlich, wenn der weg ist, haben wir von 30,
40 Prozent unserer Systeme gar keine Ahnung
mehr und wer macht das dann alles?
Aber das wurde so nicht wahrgenommen.
Ja, ja, korrekt.
Also, ich...
Ich wollte, ich wollte dazu
ein Video aufnehmen. Nicht ich, ich wollte mit einem
ehemaligen Kollege mal ein Video aufnehmen.
Zu,
ähm, Support,
wie es ist, im, im IT-Support zu arbeiten
und zum Ticket, Thema Ticket bearbeiten.
Und eine der Sachen, die wir da erzählen
wollen, werden, ich weiß nicht, ob dieses
Video jemals zustande kommt, ist,
wir haben mal eine,
nicht ganz erlaubte,
wahrscheinlich, Ticket-Analyse
gemacht. Also, dein Chef darf ja
nicht analysieren, wer macht wie viele Tickets und
sowas. Ähm,
also zumindest, zumindest nur in sehr beschränktem
Maße, aber wir haben,
ich meine, wir haben Zugriff auf das Ticket-System
gehabt, haben Admin-Rechte gehabt, das heißt, wir konnten das alles
auslesen. Wir haben mal eine Analyse gemacht,
nur für uns, zum Gucken, ob
unsere Eindrücke so stimmen.
Eine Ticket-Analyse gemacht, über
die letzten drei Jahre,
wie viele
Leute aus dem Support-Team,
wie viele Tickets,
ähm, bearbeitet haben.
Du darfst das wirklich nur unter ganz
speziellen Auflagen, so Arbeits-,
zuordnenbare Arbeitsüberwachung
und so. Frag mich nicht, ich bin da
tatsächlich nicht drin. Aber,
wir haben das nur mal für uns ausgelesen.
Und da ist
tatsächlich genau das rausgekommen,
was wir uns gedacht haben. Und zwar
jetzt mal als Beispiel, ja. Also, der
Kollege, mit dem ich das gemacht habe, der hatte, glaube ich,
1400 oder sonst was Tickets
bearbeitet.
Und wir haben so ein paar Spezialkollegen
gehabt, von denen wir gedacht haben, Alter, die machen ja gar
keine, die machen ja gar nix, ja.
Und da haben wir mal nachgeguckt
und wisst ihr, also, ein Kollege von mir
über 1400 Tickets. Und wisst ihr,
wie viele Tickets der, ähm,
der ganz unten hatte?
In der Analyse.
Drei Jahre Ticketbearbeitung. Ratet
mal. Nein, unten, nicht oben.
Ganz unten. 60.
Ja, gar nicht, gar nicht so schlecht.
Gar nicht so schlecht. Ich glaub, 84.
Ich glaub, 84 Tickets hatte
der. Also, 1400
versus 84, man.
Gut.
Natürlich ist das Ganze nicht so 100%
aussagekräftig, weil
man kann ja nur die Tickets zählen,
die quasi mit diesem Bearbeiter
dann auch geschlossen wurden und sowas.
Wenn die ein Ticket bearbeitet haben,
sich nicht als letzten Bearbeiter eingetragen haben,
geschlossen. Also gut.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so 100% aussagekräftig,
aber eine Tendenz, Trends, gibt's
auf jeden Fall, ja.
Und jetzt, um mal den Bogen zurückzumachen,
Leute. Hätte
der mit den 84 Tickets
das wirklich so dargestellt
und hätte das passend kommuniziert,
hätten wahrscheinlich alle den Eindruck gehabt,
der macht die viel krasseren Dinger,
als mein Kollege, der 1400 Tickets bearbeitet hat.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
War es nicht. War es nicht.
War alles, es war alles
Support.
Oder sagen wir mal, so Art
First Level. Alles. Wir haben nicht
Tickets von meinem Team oder so verglichen.
Das wäre ja quasi so Backend-mäßig
eher Third Level, wenn man das so
Level-technisch eingeteilt hätte.
Von damals verglichen.
Ne, ne. Nur hier die untereinander.
Oh, Max. Ich muss Caching-Zeit
noch runterstellen.
Ich hab gesagt, ich mach's nach dem Stream gestern.
Hab ich nicht gemacht. Ich wüsste gar nicht,
wo man das einstellt.
Erstens wusste ich gar nicht, dass Cloudflare
was cached. Und zweitens wusste ich
gar nicht, wo man das einstellt. Wo kann man
die Cache-Zeit einstellen in Cloudflare?
Ja, gucken wir mal. So, Leute. Jetzt.
Wisst ihr, was jetzt passiert?
Gibt's heute noch Stream?
Weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Jetzt gibt's Lachs. Nein. Falsch.
Es gibt nicht Nudeln mit Lachs.
Weil es gab letzte Woche Nudeln
mit Lachs.
Heute gibt's Nudeln mit Bolognese.
Korrekt.
So sieht's aus.
Ist der Woobloss-Stack open-source?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Das gibt's beim SeriousMax auf GitHub.
Aber ich glaube nicht alles
100% komplett, aber das meiste.
Oder alles komplett.
Ja, alles.
Also wenn ich's richtig zusammenbringe,
besteht das Woobloss-Archiv aus
Svelte Frontend,
MileySearch
FulltextSearch
für FulltextSearch,
Backend is
Go, oder?
Go Backend,
MidJourney für die Bildergenerierung
und für das
Transcribe-Ding Whisper
AI, oder?
Ich glaube, das ist richtig.
Also Whisper, MidJourney,
Svelte und Go.
Und
Miley FulltextSearch.
Ich glaube, das ist der Woobloss-Stack.
Also der ist
hinter dem
Woobloss-Archiv.
MidJourney fürs Generieren der Thumbnails.
Whisper AI
fürs
Transcribe-
Bin?
Kommt man das nicht runter da?
Fürs Transcribe, weil man kann hier zum Beispiel suchen nach Keckel,
wo ich Keckel sage,
im Stream, sogar mit Timestamp.
Frontend ist Svelte, Backend ist Go.
Ja, ist richtig, richtig Pog.
Übrigens, ich find dieses Resitas
Comic-Style-Bild einfach
zu geil.
Gebt es mal einen Stream drüber.
Naja, ich kann noch keinen Stream
drüber machen, weil ich hab das ja nicht entwickelt.
Wo ist der Max-Stream?
Oh, ich gar nicht weiß,
ob er überhaupt Max heißt, aber
vermute mal, ja.
Das kann ich, also
ich mein, wir könnten das vielleicht mal
zeigen in irgendeinem Stream, wie das funktioniert,
aber da liegen wir vielleicht zu viel.
Also guck, hier ist
das Source-Code dazu, das
Woobloss-Archiv.
Der Max ist eh sehr feifett, was GitHub-Sachen
angeht, weil, ihr werdet feststellen,
er hat hier einen Repo mit
946 Sternen.
Guckt euch mal die Readme hiervon an.
Und guckt euch mal die Readme hiervon an.
Permission denied, public key.
Oh, was ist das?
Guckt euch mal die
Readme hiervon an. Entdeckt ihr
vielleicht ein paar
Ähnlichkeiten?
Also gewisse Ähnlichkeiten sind, glaube ich,
aus der Readme schon zu erkennen, oder?
Ich hab einfach
seine Readme geklaut und angepasst.
Ja, Leute,
der Server ist auch super feifett.
Der Sebaru hat irgendeinen eigenen
Server gemietet,
mit einem Kollege von ihm,
der aber aktuell nur über IPv6
erreichbar ist. Allerdings
nicht einfach nur über IPv6.
Sie haben sich ein eigenes
IPv6-BGP-routbares
Provider-Netz
gekauft. Fragt mich nicht, was
sie da treiben im Hintergrund. Ich hab damit nichts zu tun.
Das ist super weird, ja?
Sie haben sich irgendwie
ein Provider eingetragen, haben ein eigenes
BGP-Netz
bekommen und
IPv6 routbar.
Und da steht jetzt irgendwie der Server. Und damit das
überhaupt noch geht, muss da vorne ein
Cloudflare-Proxy, der IPv4 auf
IPv6 macht. Leute, es ist
ultra weird, aber das Archiv
funktioniert wunderbar.
Okay, Leute, ich geh jetzt was fordern. Wir hören uns.
Bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.